[Music]
so
[Music]
yes sir
what is going on around
how are we doing out there
the final
ilp 2021 season finale what's going on
gerald mack what's going on let me know
how i'm sounding mr joanna dark i see
what's going on death mobile what's up
sick slayer what's going on you already
know akw what's going on
top of the morning top of the morning to
y'all
let me know how we doing out here
it's gonna be a great show yeah what's
going on jorge luis bettencourt yo
what's going on
d nasty what's up what up guys
man a little tired a little tight what
am i right i appreciate y'all thank you
for the sound check
you know what i mean so yeah we got some
fun in the room the final one 2021 we
got lady april
in the building aka lady lyric
a little tired a little tired but i saw
that spider-man last night
crazy crazy i ain't gonna spoil it but
definitely crazy
if you're a fan of mcu i highly
recommend you see this one
it's crazy deep oh without the lord's
day that's right sunday y'all know what
it is the bottom one because we the
lords do need a break
so we will take two weeks off after this
but um d nancy i know you got some
fights to talk oh
yeah
shout out to dude wipes though d nancy
if you know that reference shout out to
dude white they got a bag messing with
tyro woodley
yeah that was crazy i think might have
something to say on that we'll see
okay that when we get ladybug oh i would
love i would love to have
[ __ ] the queen
queen would love to have her on we'll
definitely try to work to make that
happen hopefully next year that'll be
dope halo yeah i see y'all
a lot of stuff going on a lot of stuff
going on below let me get by here i'm
gonna go grab up the lady of our
lady lyric and get her in here and um
oh
okay the dutchman what's going on
appreciate you hustling thank you
brother i appreciate it yeah the final
sunday of the year 2021 close-out show
gonna have some fun we're gonna talk it
up
oh christopher this is gonna be a crazy
show you already don't care
you already know what's going on anyway
i will see y'all in a bit let me go grab
up the lady of the hour and i will talk
to y'all
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
[Music]
for them to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look
gotta mess up and turn me to an animal
and haters be swearing they real but
come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start it regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got
[Music]
you i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arcing up in the apartment they
call the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
rings you just a target when
um
[Music]
i'm embarrassed for you i've always been
a nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
messaging people on aim
check
[Music]
your dog thing very loyal but i ain't
gonna hold you i ain't here to boy you
ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed for
you i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rains
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals follow on twitter but
i'm anti-social lower my city but i'm
still by coastal
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell the uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
all on twitter but i'm anti-social love
my city but i'm still by coastal i got
it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell the uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that
again you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and had this be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they wanna compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing that
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say it
i'm embarrassed for you i always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
that's who
let's do it
[Music]
i'ma just chill and watch them any
snacks in the attic i wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they would mistake me for
addict if i can imagine it's cool to
give you some advice and invite your
girl to your squadron cause if you don't
give her that option you gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be me though i know
it's my
that's cool but i got bad news even if
you really was that jew king david still
be the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible wasn't it nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
[Music]
all right
and we
are live hear you hear ye and welcome to
the iron lords podcast llc and also live
on lords of gaming.net episode number
238 it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
date i'm extremely excited about our
special guest and we've got the splinter
cell remake announcement
power on xbox documentary and ilp's 2021
season finale to discuss so we go get
right into it
i want to introduce a lady whose
insatiable passion for writing gaming
and all things geeky truly make her an
up-and-coming force within the realm of
content creation and female gamer
empowerment
introducing the creating host of the
blazing nitro podcast an esteemed writer
for lordsofgaming.net
the lady of kingdom hearts final fantasy
and persona
who always puts the pedal to the metal
for us all to just geek out
live from ohio and making her log net
debut in the realm of the lords
my girl lady april pence aka lyric a i
love how we doing sis
i love that
let's get it how are we doing
after that intro i'm doing amazing she's
like i'm going home
thank you i appreciate that
the
lady at what you do always appreciate
your contributions long overdue in the
room what have you been playing since
uh well
i've been replaying persona 5.
okay i've been replaying tech and seven
oh wait wait wait hold on hold on he's
just gonna slide in some tech in love
like like you know what i'm saying like
the lord's gonna get down with this
what's your character yeah let's go
okay so
i mean oscar and josie
and juaren oh
oh
wait a minute use a flamingo oh
oh okay
find out wow this is new this is new
[Laughter]
okay so who's your go to yeah who's the
one like who's your go to when you when
you when you're getting there and you
start mixing it up and that dude win
that one match and you're like oh no
hell no not today
who's that go to
oh my
frozen
all-out fighters josie oh okay
no no no doubt shout out to josie yeah
she she got added she got added more
recently right you know like what more
recent seconds i do remember someone
said to josie that's it so anything else
you've been playing besides that
um
i have sims
sims 4
and sims 3. so so persona of
april are you playing royale are you
going just probably playing og persona
5.
vanilla personality okay
okay okay okay no doubt no doubt i don't
know if attic i know just jumped out and
said he's going to reborn i see him
there but we'll make sure he's good at
it you go
nah he in the bushes okay
but yeah he said he's going to reboot so
uh you know we got those four horsemen
in the realm but hopefully attic will
jump right back off for the reboot but
we got the most technical gaming lord
the solo game who lives with a single
player selfish experience and also the
sastradamus the lord of clarity and lord
patron of the iron bank
my man fresh off that spider-man with me
last night lord sovereign how we doing
i'm in the bushes but i'm feeling good
i'm feeling glad to have april here my
partner for the lord's minute on a
weekly basis lately april in the
building um we're if you guys don't know
we're known for being very brief with
our oh no
[Laughter]
that was that that was that y'all are 20
minutes
i know you talk about
time is a flat circle sir i don't know
yeah yes it is time is irrelevant to you
sir
you implying that we have we have a very
brisk pace when it comes to intros in
the room some people do i don't know
about them but i know it when i get down
my lord's minute you know we're in five
minutes in and out you know the way it
is
lady let me know about the beast they'd
be like oh did you get solved under
control because
he going extra with the lord's minute
that'd be 20 minutes
i i heard it was supposed to be a
10-minute cap
but my man's over here though
yeah i know you're like man why why
can't you get away with it
at the end of every video we apologize
to pete for having
[Laughter]
oh
that was that was a moment uh
for us to i'm old man i can't be doing
late night movies anymore that was crazy
but
i would tell you this when we walked
into that theater and there was a line
going down the escalators to people
this
spider-man the anticipation for it was
different i mean you saw people in
costumes it's something that at this
theater we normally don't see at this
particular theater that we go to
and it was just you could see the
excitement for it and it and it lived up
to it so that that was that was
something special
gameplay wise i had i haven't even
gotten a touch halo infinite this whole
week i'm so mad at myself but
what i did do is i managed to secure the
king collapse i managed to secure an o.g
foreman grill
100 back compact ps3 since my idiot
stuff got rid of mine back back when um
who was that that was not sean layton
who was that that was um that casseroy
was the castle right i think casseroy
was in charge around that time yeah yeah
yeah yeah
you need another job
the famous words yeah favorite favorite
last words
we have those dudes so since sony does
not appear to care about their legacy i
i had to go out and do what i did yeah
exactly
you do so you swiped twice i swiped
twice no it was free it was free thank
you
yeah so again i i did when i saw when
when i saw the opportunity no no no i
saw the opportunity somebody was you
know getting rid of it and they didn't
care for what it meant so i was like oh
i do though oh wow that was a comeback
[Music]
yeah from sony themselves
it
yo so first i downloaded some of the og
ps1 games real fast
i threw on i love a siphon filter so i
threw one inside yeah
wow that does not hold up at all
he said wow he set it up
but but but it was nice to have so good
that's nice but it's sir that's been it
that's been it uh i'll read these super
tests afterwards all right no doubt and
of course while we're waiting for attic
we got the incredible hulk of this aka
the access gamer oh the prophet of xbox
king
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
b
love it laura king how are we doing sir
better than tyler on woodley oh
shout out to the dude
shout out to dude wipes though dude
wife's got a bag
yo okay i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna lie yeah yeah man
went to the shadow realm yeah like he
got hit and he got checked out it was
like finish him
and he did the soul snatcher
i haven't seen it yet i'm going to watch
it right now watch it like that
first i knew he was gonna lose second i
knew he wasn't in shape third i knew he
didn't
[Music]
see that yeah yeah he's out of control
yes he's out of control he's out of
control so he gonna let that jay paul do
go and j
they really training yeah yeah they're
really working let's go puerto rico baby
jake paul and pr doing his thing
he's really working on he's not doing it
i don't know he lives over there
he's taking
what i've seen it looks like is like
these
these ufc and fighters like
like oh he's just a youtuber so they're
like i don't have to do anything and
then they get knocked out because of it
and they now respect them boxing let's
just call it one no this is this is
entertainment this is not a fight hey
let's be real it's the biggest bag they
ever gonna see yeah ufc dudes let's keep
it a buck
i gotta give tyron um you know he got
back in the ring i knew it was gonna end
bad for him
you're gonna look soft yeah
thank you for saying that because i
showed my wife the the weigh-in
and then i said he looks he looks in
shape right here right she's like yeah
he looks decent i said check this out i
went to one of his ufc fights when he
was champion yeah i said check that out
i said you see a hard body pause
that's what he's supposed to look like
anyway um
spiderman oh
let's get it
from the opening scene and i went to the
4dx movie theater in new rock city he
flexed it everybody was in there with
costumes and stuff like that they took
pictures of the whole movie they waited
for everybody to get seated before they
started the movie which was absolutely
insane
they're supposed to start at six o'clock
they started at 6 45 to wait for
everybody from the concessions to get
all these stuff to be seen
um
total fan service from beginning to end
kevin feige and the team
um at marvel
and that's sony mm-hmm sorry sorry too
yeah facts they
they did the unthinkable they pulled off
the incredible
um
my wife was sitting there like what the
hell did people's she stood up cause
it's like everybody in the movie theater
could we take a picture with y'all and i
sat down and i had my like i had this
little um happy sad fast mask on yeah
i'm in a witness protection program
but it was it was amazing um
y'all dudes
keep fronting on my man's name put some
respect on field dominus maximus arula
spencer's name man
spider-man
no no no i'm not even talking about that
i'm in game pass right now oh okay okay
i had i had to put this on
ten games day in in one day
and i told you dealer i told you who
else came at me
i was like king if you like a game you
gotta buy the game when it comes out
mortal kombat 11 inside my game
nothing
you waited hard work
same people the same people that say
that like do they be buying the witcher
season
through when it comes when it comes out
like
like dude do they do they be doing like
any of these like popular tv shows no
where's that loki season one guys where
is it
i don't pay none of these dudes anymore
mm-hmm because it felt like a new
release to me
like i yo this the stuff that they
dropped in there
first i finished the halo campaign
and again i might be a prisoner of the
moment
um because i
a lot of times this week i've been a
prisoner i said spider-man is the best
marvel movie period
um and that's lofty i got other stuff
that's dead it's lovely because i love
asian ultron it's past that
um
this halo
343
this is the best halo period and i don't
care what anybody gonna tell me go pick
up the the the first one go pick up any
one of your halos that you love so much
and sit next to me side by side see if
your master chief move like mine
he do not do that
exactly and then
the removal of cgi except for the
opening scene i think that was something
i already crafted earlier on the removal
of cgi
and allowing the game to breathe and do
what it's supposed to do i know the
ending is a little cop out yeah it
worked for me i feel that i feel that
car no doubt no doubt addict is back
with his bike so we got to hook him up
my co-host with the cold most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror lord of his own world and the
how of the young wolf no longer young
wolf happy boring day lord attic how we
doing sir
pretty good bad tired still i don't know
that's what happens when you turn 45
bro how you doing
oh it's it was good now you're gonna
have to thinking you're gonna have
people thinking in the chat that i
really am 40 no i'm not 40. we got to
spread the propaganda yeah
but you
like obviously like spider-man
i can honestly say that
there's very few people that could have
made this movie work like very few
people like
the amount
like there is a hundred different
universes where this this story gets
like
it doesn't make sense
and like
they everyone over there not just uh you
know not just
man i already forgot his name i just
not just
everyone over there needs a race
because
to put so many variables in a movie and
make it make sense in a good movie along
with making sure it's constant
entertainment it's hard to do yes yep
yes every every thread every
no missteps they're just the the content
from
three different storylines
and
the ultimate fan service yeah we ain't
spoiling the double end we got you it's
awesome
no no no no no no no no no no no i'm
looking at the chat it's just yeah i'm
with you but yeah
when you told me he was like go see it
and he was like yo i'm telling you guys
call me out and i was like yeah it's
it's like you said i can't say it's rare
that they live up to hype okay what else
what you've been playing though
yeah and i i will say that like when it
comes to spider-man like i don't think
it's the best marvel movie ever man okay
but i i do think i i would give infinity
war above it because i feel like there's
a lot of stuff infinity war had going
for the thanos and
i feel like that really carried that
movie above it but this is like
right there with yeah
yeah anybody can say that can we
definitively say king
the best spider-man
no it's the best spider-man film period
it's like like halo infinite
um i feel like this this is sins like
spider-man like what they did in this
movie this is like avengers level stuff
yeah they call it a spider-man game
and if the numbers is going to reflect
how good it is
i can't and it's better than in-game by
the way from listen when i'm telling you
from beginning yeah to
everything let's just stay in the movie
there don't leave until they tell you
get out okay
cross bronx expressway and then and the
bx at the top did you catch that did you
catch that 95 so i was like
i caught my job
the warehouse is at
everything
i'm just i'm
too much i'm too much i'm too i want to
go upstairs and play spider-man yeah
facts that's too much yeah facts sorry i
had it good we we ips it only
yeah but i i i enjoyed it man uh as far
as like games
i really played much this week uh i've
been doing a lot of uh
other stuff
currently
no it's just my toothache man no no no
no what are you sorry about what
happened what you do
i don't know we're going to you know oh
and we was trying to make it work so bad
that had nothing to do with anyone man i
just my tooth was hurting so much like
my thing is like i didn't want to start
it and have to end it in like 40 minutes
because it just randomly like the more i
talk the worse it gets yeah
you can just shut up and let's just let
me find out that you it was you
always just blame yourself
yeah that's been about it i'm waiting
for that dying light too no doubt no
doubt and of course we have the gaming
ninja himself the shinobi lord cognito
spreading that renaissance around the
iop not telling what you want to hear
but what you need to hear again we
talked about spider-man you already know
what it is go see it it's fire shout out
to defining dude we had that up a
mystery plays go check that out talk a
little bit of that stalker nft stuff
little splinter cell which we will get
into here in the realm and um yeah on
the patreon shout out to uh colin aka
cobra commander colin moriarty i call
him here with everybody got a good um
defining duke oh i caught a coke back
because you always wearing like gi joe
cover stuff and i love it oh yeah that's
what's up so salute
yeah they got uh duke up with about
bioware it's fire it's fire so check
that out shout out to the last word my
bros evontis ty got travis i was back in
the saddle had my man kevin osx fire we
talked about studio culture what's going
on it's kind of crazy over there right
now it's kind of crazy so we had to
address that um we talked about of the
dawning and the 30th anniversary for me
yeah just kind of getting back on my
halo ground you know
rocking and rolling just loving the
verticality having fun with it you know
did a couple of uh fights uh high value
target fights just kind of i'm taking my
time just exploring the map i don't want
to rush to me can i ask you a question
let's go was you able to do that in any
other halo no no and and to be honest
with you king i know where you at it's
like
i'm a purist so i was very
skeptical of open world
right now
but like there's a feeling of you with
your crew
like i take it personally with the
burritos dog oh yeah
oh no they don't kill him they killed
bobby they killed her like i tried to
hook them up addict i'm speaking to him
because he was telling me how his
brother be hooking everybody up with
snapchat so i'm trying to unlock the
snipers and the beast because i want
them kitted out i wanted to jump in the
warhol like i got a gang with me and
we're gonna run through this map so
that's where i make sure i don't take
the dude with the t-shirts like y'all
t-shirts dudes is going to stay at the
base i'm just going to take the dude
with the armor
doing that t-shirt
out there fighting brutes with a t-shirt
i did i did this
it's like bruce was cause i'm playing on
a heroic joint so bruce was baby
sometimes you got to get up out of there
you don't want to run you know
you already got the one hitter yeah so
it was this poor little marine and i had
freed her and i kind of used us
yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry larry don't
don't judge me lately don't judge me
don't judge me i had i kind of said i
could pick them off and her service was
very appreciated she died for the cause
so salute to her but anyway
that's been it for me on that you wanna
get did you see what you saw before we
get it yeah no doubt so uh we got
gameonomics remember for two months what
the crest of the chapter gaming now
makes for lord bronze thank you so much
then we got michael aka bet styles fine
it's five dollar super chat shout out
shootout shoot out to the lord
and all of it i hope all of you are well
now that we got that out of the way ps
is trash no cap king pain to the
playstation community god bless wow we
got them bing bong
michael michael sounds like he hasn't
had his coffee yet yeah it's just mad
like he rolled out of bed and he just
started talking trash in my playstation
we got lord of roughness five five super
chat hello from the uk to my faves the
iron lords what a year it's been for us
gamers well uh xbox ones anyway wow
series s and game pass is king okay okay
yes this is true
then we have the dutch runner five
dollars if we check cog
i listened to defining duke and what is
this i hear that you do chicken see wow
y'all ruffled my feathers with that and
it's clucked up y'all foul
listen all that all that chicken stuff
that's that's the defining duke last
time media thing
they just be throwing it on me i just
like i don't know what's going on i
don't even know what they were talking
about until i had to find out the
history so that's constantly found out
you found out that earlier
okay so
let's just just look up ernie and astis
our our very own new york city guys
look look up ernie and ask this
effing the chicken that's it i don't
know they running with this inside joke
so that is not
that creative right here
that's last video you know though
whatever they talk
a lot you know how uh what you may call
it like a anchor sometimes you know have
little faux pas on on live yeah this was
a faux pas and all four pass like it was
like whoa
they paused him they had to pause him
two dollar super chat by 80 your
grandfather picked up lil man and game
pass wow god bless no doubt
oh you
thank you so much brother blessings we
appreciate it man what's up lords happy
holidays everyone onward and upwards
king i will hit you up but i don't like
transferring negative energy and have
and i haven't been in the best state of
mind we understand brother it's been a
hard year for everybody i know you've
been through some stuff man so we're
here for you bro does um anytime you
want to talk i'm in there to listen if
you if you know you know how we do we
get into a chapter and just chill and
say we can talk about fights
trust me i can help you dispel that
negative energy and i can help you
remove all that stuff not the issue
right just the feelings right now i feel
like brother i feel that i'll make you
laugh oh yeah he's hilarious yes
what else you got
the dutch rudder five dollar stupid chat
it's magical season but it's also hard
for many tell your friends and family
that you love them and sometimes people
will just feel alone during christmas
then we got michael aka best size finest
once again the gunk is a pretty solid
game lords check it out also
updated outriders give it a go yeah yeah
i got to get on that yeah king i might
have to hit you up with that
okay mm-hmm i really like i still have
my modded guns
but i might need to take a basic dude
guys are super powerful i don't want to
be carried like that
i'm running with my mo
the guy who got the mighty guns
again we got heart get chini five dollar
super chat the last iop of 2021 epic
year for xbox i guess playstation and
nintendo did some things too vodka
i can't say this
it is dry over there
dudes got popeye biscuits and no water
oh
ridiculous god i can't even just
thinking about that hurts um we got don
otaku 10 super chat as a huge fan of
image and form and the steam world games
the gunk is the most disappointed i've
been in the game since the original
watchdogs doesn't even feel like it's
the same depth okay okay i gotta i
haven't tried it yet myself but that's
that's disappointing to hear um gaming
14 five dollar super chat by a large
group i thought it feels like it was
made by a small group
anyway it does seem like it's their
first uh 3d kind of foray everything
else has been two days so
gaming for today five dollar super chat
happy holidays lords love and miss you
guys and as always hey king boo-boo
you got to jump on man let me know
hopefully you're not working we haven't
felt like i've never had 14 in a long
time in a minute
with that mini fridge yeah even the mini
fridge out selling the playstation 5.
got him
all right last of the last one last one
that's what lord metroid two dollar
super chat king check rich the boxing
historian on youtube
um
salute thank you for a great year enjoy
your time off hurry back all hail the
iop salute thank you lord mac always
repping
yeah he always beautiful thing always
rapping so so let's get into that we got
to what the lords have been playing we
gotta focus on lady lyric
her journey into journalism and content
creation and of course we'll learn how
to becoming the esteemed freelance
writer for many reputable sites
including our very own loyaltygaming.net
so ladylike let's start from the very
beginning what was some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming
uh so the first video game system that i
remember playing uh i remember i was
four my brother was seven and it was the
genesis
let's talk some games throw some genesis
games though what's up oh yeah uh the
power rangers movie game okay mickey's
castle oh oh let's go how do i see why
you were song
now that vicky was fired continue contra
oh
okay
okay that was contra hall corpse right
yes
hey ladies
go ahead
uh we also had the n64 with twisted
metal okay okay cause i believe that was
was it twisted though um just a matter
which playstation but what was this so
what was the game the car wrecking game
you played on n64 yeah it was demolition
it was um
um bulldoze it was the bulldozer um yeah
crash cor something core
last chord
and that was kind of lit like for me
yeah i forgot who made that game let me
look that up okay okay what else
one of the games we also had playstation
the first playstation and the second one
so on the first play station it was like
spyro
my brother had the
third tekken not the first one oh that
that's arguably the best
yeah like tekken 3 was a thing yeah for
sure
then they did tech and tag after two
right
was the
launch title on the ps4 or the ps4 yeah
the ps2 right yeah so i remember that
when the mouse started
i remember you guys that was the first
time that cog
went and did did a king and bought and
bought a japanese place i can't wait to
take it
not to cut lyric like but that was
literally the first time i spent like a
grand for a costume and i didn't care it
was it was i was getting that ps2 and
that i could not have that tekken tag
out there in that street and i remember
because that was when imports were a
year early mm-hmm she came over to my
house and saw it and said that's it
that's it
i don't know what i did to get there i
don't know either
but we made it happen
uh
another like very vivid memory of like
gaming is when my dad would take me and
my brother to pizza hut and they had the
mk4 arcade machine stand up and we would
play it while we were waiting for our
pizza wow
that's fire like that that's what's up
arcade upright okay okay so you pretty
much
went from um she probably had like a
little bit of everything yeah
playstation
and 64. so after
ps2
then like where did you where did you
transition from
so
our playstation 2 was christmas 2000 and
yeah chris was 2000 and i remember when
we got it
and
me and my brother immediately ran
upstairs he hooked it up
he also got the original xbox one
i remember that because the first xbox
that was when
that was the system that we first played
daily alliance and deception on and we
beat both of those games okay okay you
guys are big mk fans in that family yeah
we're also big dbz budokai fans
deadly alliance
that was the dc
no that was the first 3d the first one
that had like 3d polygons okay yeah okay
so yeah that was yeah i remember that
one because that one went up against uh
dark gods
dark gods and yeah
that that was pretty good um my best
mortal kombat is uh mortal kombat versus
dc
and
i loved it because they wasn't doing
fatality because they didn't want them
to do fatalities
yeah yeah you can give supreme beat
downs yeah
i love things
so talk about that um attic i don't know
if these thoughts have a low camera
issue but uh do you approve of the the
dbz stuff well dbz builder car yes
yeah i like the budape franchise i like
that
the tenkaichi franchise more to be
honest with you okay okay okay yeah
tenkaichi is better
except for buddha cat 3 buddha cat 3 is
king to me always okay okay okay that's
what's up so
i'm sorry sorry about that no the chat
concurs budokai 3 is so damn good amit
kumar says that no questions of course
so you get into the xbox ecosystem so i
get a lot of fighting games now
i we know you for a lot of
the what i would say like to say jrpgs
but a lot of you know personas the final
fantasy like i'm trying to see like when
that the playstation thing kind of like
transitioned hard what was the games
that kept you on the platform was it
those particularly like that's what i'm
trying to get engaged i noticed there's
a lot of love for you in that in those
genres in those games specifically
oh yeah uh the story of how i got into
kingdom hearts and what kept me with
what kept me in square enix and all that
so i had the final fantasy x okay well
final fantasy 10 i call it
interchangeable but i love that games so
much and when it came out with kingdom
hearts 2 the first time i saw the game
was in a game exchange
and i saw goofy and donald on the cover
and my dad was like you can have one
game pick one game and i picked kingdom
hearts and we took it home and me and my
brother played it and i immediately fell
in love with it
[Music]
so much so so much so that when the
announcement and game informer for
kingdom hearts 2 came
you know hit i cut it out and taped it
to my bedroom wall
like that so what was it about kingdom
hearts that you really felt it was the
the characters the story was it was the
disney characters or was it like are we
going to interrogate everyone that comes
on this show that yes
yes exactly
is my camera messy no you go
you're good you're good
yeah he was going in and out of the
matrix yeah you're back
i think it says windows 11 yeah i don't
love it would force it to update on you
that's crazy but yeah okay so let's get
into the kingdom hearts mentality what
is the passion like what's all this
saying
oh well the passion is right here
the character files
so it's the is the character is it more
the
is it more like the square characters or
is it more like the disney characters
that disney characters have been big for
you since you've been small or is it
just the the combination of the two that
really draws you in
so it was the distant characters that
got me to pick the game up but it was
the square characters and i'm a square
enix fan all the way so like i'm the
biggest final fantasy 15 apologist
let me ask you a question right um
because attic uh tells me that the the
story is convoluted to a point where you
jump from
uh console to console uh
game the game
and you have to play a certain order oh
hold on i just want to ask her
did you follow them
all and play all those games from
[Music]
game console the console
uh story distort because attic can sit
there and explain it to me
right and he'll tell me which one to
play first don't play that one first
play this one first because that one
won't make sense if you play this one
first so did did you get a chance to
play everything to make everything make
sense because i think real fans of that
um i'm not saying real fans but
fans of the storyline a lot of them
watch the story on youtube they actually
just you know figure it out and and can
tell you because attic is like a supreme
fan when it comes to this yeah so the
story is very
not convoluted it makes sense when you
like really sit down and read it
like
it's the problem of namura getting
infatuated with a system wanting to put
a game on that system
and fans having to scramble to buy a new
system
okay the pro the problem with
kingdom hearts is not a complicated
story the reason it's complicated is
because of just okay you know let's make
a prequel five years later let's one's
really going to be four let let's let's
have the story totem on like five
different platforms so like there's a
chance at least
ha one of every three people didn't
play this game and they didn't play this
game then they were going to put the
mobile game as the one that starts at
all like
i always joke that if namura could have
put lore on kingdom hearts v cast he
would have
like
yeah that's i mean that i think to me
like that that's the biggest point when
you tell me like that the ones that are
on game boy
um are like can't like core storyline
can and i'm like wait a minute you're
killing me
there are no side names in kingdom
yeah that's the only thing the only the
only game you can miss and not miss too
much is uh is kingdom hearts chain of
memories that's the only one and you'll
miss certain stuff on that one but
that's the only one you'll miss that i
would say throughout the story won't you
won't lose too much knowledge from like
it doesn't that's all and that's that's
even a rhythm game right it's like is
canon
yeah oh my god
yep
that's crazy that's crazy it's all
cannon
yeah you're muted
yeah thank you for catching that oh no
that's crazy i didn't even know that
that was good
so when they told me the mobile game is
like the originator and you have to play
this
what's crazy
watch it on youtube you don't want to
play uh
there's a mobile game
and
it what they did is because in kingdom
hearts three
you you you you fight this uh you you
fight the last boss with these things
called the uh
uh the keys uh the keys of tamar or
something like that it's like every
keyblade of every keyblade wielder and
if if you look at the little thing on
the top left the bottom left it's every
every key belongs to someone in that
mobile game like they put all the roster
of all the members into the game through
that
so i want to go back with it so it's
like dad says like one game right and
you got to pick that so they you cut
this thing out you put it out and then
like they make it happen for you like
what's that feeling like when it when it
went down when he was able to get it
oh the first time i played through
kingdom hearts too like
it was a moment of
i reacted to kingdom hearts too the way
that my brother reacted to getting jade
empire for the first time where he was
okay
like he literally ran and tripped up the
stairs going to empire
[Laughter]
that was me with kingdom hearts too that
was also me with kingdom hearts 3 when
it shipped to the house because i
pre-ordered it
which was a disappointment
and how old were you guys when you were
playing these games because again
i didn't really get into like well i i
played rpgs
young but i think a lot of kids kind of
get into the action games first to sort
of uh
watching
license games and then they get into
more hardcore stuff i got into kingdom
hearts because
i saw in a game of former magazine i
could fight sephiroth from final fantasy
vii so the only reason i played the game
at first
and
it took me a minute to that that is by
far like one of the most annoying bosses
you could ever fight in kingdom hearts
so just like like what's always saying
like what what just
to his question you say like around the
time like you guys were playing it
so kingdom hearts 2 came out in 2002
when i was eight
okay wow wow
that's that that's hardcore
that's what's up that's what's up so you
go from that okay and then like i said
you do get a xbox and then i'm noticing
a lot of fighting a lot of fighting
games in there the more kind of stuff
and then from there do you do
360 at all or no
so 360 came out
2005 and that was my brother's christmas
gift from my dad okay
so we did play 360 and we played me and
my brother
were really big into the star wars games
nato republic
yeah and he beat that in like one night
i remember that distinctly did you did
you play the the xbox gem obi-wan the
first obi-wan king
how did how did that red ring of death
creature
oh i distinctly remember him running
into my dad's and i was like oh my god i
got the red ring and we had to ship it
to the xbox headquarters and they show
us a new one
you know i never got the red ring like
not one time i never got the red ring
well you lucked out i know every day one
dude
we get into we get into the documentary
yeah
no question no question so you got that
you stay on 360 for a while and then
like i said from that point it's just
every system that comes out whether it
be ps3
and you still continue or you kind of
stay on one platform moving forward
so we stuck with a 360 for a while i
remember
he got a playstation 3 because he had a
summer job okay so he was able to get
into playstation 3. and we played deader
[Music]
we played devil may cry 4 on the
playstation 3.
no question no question ps3 with the
foreman grill saw with the
the back of patrick oh yeah
yeah when they built the ps2 into the
playstation 3 that those are the good
old days yeah yeah
yeah that's that's when they were caring
about the fans and then somebody and
somebody said what the hell are you
doing
it's costing us a boatload
a lot of people don't remember when they
had playstation home which was like the
hub yeah yes
i loved that when you had your own
little home okay so it was like my space
but it was a virtual space if anybody
understands what myspace is what are
they supposed to bring that back in some
way what my space they think
yo my space is about to come back
am i about to make a comeback my space
actually my they're that that's back but
we don't talk i'm talking about home
oh no
that playstation home was fun
and then they
it just like phased it out like people
could walk into your playstation
it turned into i guess what nfts is
turning into or whatever where you can
have your virtual space and people can
come inside your house and pause and and
and see all your stuff your like your
furniture and stuff and oh i made a
garden here and stuff it was it was
ahead of its time yeah and i don't think
they're like um the internet
infrastructure this their services were
up to snuff to like to convey that to uh
to to the masses because
at that period of time you know
broadband wasn't readily available to a
lot of people so even loading in that we
already had broadband because we were
doing stuff you know that needed it um
to load in on a dial up into home it was
just it wasn't worth it i forgot all
about home to be honest like i'm trying
to remember it now it was what was it
like a virtual space like it's like that
that xbox museum was like um you could
play like second life for like you you i
remember couldn't you play like checkers
in the mall area or something like that
with other people people was all
populated and like
it was like okay you know when you have
your little knees yes when you when you
first had your ds and if you see a
little me that was in the area yeah so
people can come to your area and it's
populated
it was such a great idea
and they just dropped it because i don't
think the tech was there but the tech is
there now and they if i think if they
would pick it up yeah i mean they could
do it for something i mean they can do
it
that would work yes
facebook might still let up really
quickly yeah that's a place i forgot all
about that lady lyric that's what's up
that's what's up so continue on with
that you know i mean and then um
next generation consoles you you're back
in the mix or we're we're both or wait
wait wait wait from there
so by the time the playstation 4 came
out my brother had already moved out you
know
he had had his first daughter and
everything so he had an xbox one
so i didn't have an xbox one but i did
have a playstation 4 and i remember i
bought it because what you bought it for
king
but i knew it was going to be announced
so i was like let me grab it right
right got that kicked
why would they grabbed it for kingdom
hearts 3 and they didn't come out for
five
years lot of times we purchase these
consoles on hope yeah yeah sometimes it
pays off like i don't buy games on hope
that it comes to game pass
but it go it goes to show you right like
if you're a fan of a franchise it means
a software like appreciate it's like
you would hold out because you knew it
was coming to that platform right and
that's why i know we were talking about
you know the little thing being solved
about you know persona and you know
things like that because like lady
lyrics she's an example of that right
like she's literally like yo kingdom
hearts or whatever like so these are her
full sizes and she's going to get on a
platform where she could pretty much
guarantee it's going to be this it's
going to be there yeah it's important
how do you feel now that phil dominance
maximus are really spencer has brought
over the whole franchise of our kingdom
hearts over does it give you
uh hope that uh kingdom hearts will
launch day and date on both platforms
this time i mean for for the future
kingdom hearts i mean i mean
this time kingdom hearts
yeah it did but no the better question
the better question is how do you feel
it wasn't in game fast but it was there
no the better question is how you feel
that we lost all the final fantasies
here going out what's this
that's the better forever we can't keep
them out
i mean like listen if you didn't play it
when it was dead that's on you booboo on
you but you can still go purchase it
though go get that
so so i i can purchase the final fantasy
7 remake on uh the xbox i don't know i
don't care listen i don't i can purchase
16 on xbox but that game didn't come out
yet
i can purchase final i can purchase
final fantasy 14 on xbox are you living
in the future addict
apparently act like this
it's way in the future we're gonna sit
here
we're gonna stay here and be like oh
ain't you glad that phil spencer brought
you kingdom hearts three but act like
that's the last stuff that we got
i mean you you were excited i remember
oh no until the until look until they
start having stuff consistently come out
i can't give them that they just gave
you 15 games go back now
15 games 13 games man go back did you
check your gameplay see i do it daily
hey hey hey why don't you go play final
fantasy 7 on game pass right now did it
come out
did it yeah go go play it it came out in
games anymore because you know what
happens
if it's not there and i ain't buy it it
don't exist it was there
it was there for a whole year what
happened to you
right now let's be focused back but i'm
speaking out about everything forever
i wanted to get into also was was uh
what ps4 was the persona series another
factor because i know you have a little
that series
oh i love the persona series like of
course i grab what happened with persona
5 was i bought another franchise we
can't get king
yeah i bought my playstation 4 and
i didn't have the extra money to buy any
games so my dad came home from work and
he he saw me he's like you have a system
but you don't have nothing to play on it
and he was like tomorrow we'll go to
walmart i'll grab you a game pick out
any game so i grew up at five
and unfortunately because i've looked 14
since i was 17 the lady who i'm pretty
sure i was older than was like you need
to be 18
and i was like
i'm
22. you hit it with your id
busting them off with your id like don't
hold on she was like excuse me oh miss
you're gonna have to have a guardian
here for this
who let you in the store
i always say i always say if i get
pulled over by the police i'm gonna act
like i don't have my id so they just
return me to my parents
i'm an unaccompanied mom
let me ask you a question
did you play the first persona
uh
the very first one i haven't played that
one now but i did play the second one
okay
sovereign out of control with that stuff
yeah i mean
yeah yeah she i mean she's a little
young pursuit coding but oh man yeah you
need to play
i would suggest you play you know uh
persona four again but that's not coming
to xbox so you're gonna have to play
that one oh wait wait wait you talking
about the one that i have um for my
playstation 4
we're talking about xbox one
everything's good on xbox but when it's
on wait you coming at me for something i
purchased
boycott
okay oh yeah wait wait wait time
so you you purchase on your playstation
yeah yeah i do
see i don't trust them so i bought it
the disc
i don't trust them i don't i don't think
that's right i don't put my credit card
in i don't get no digits and i did when
i did it i got burnt so
i don't do it anymore and i just buy
physical for them physical will always
be a thing
but you know you're a huge head-to-head
fighter why don't you pick up that
persona fighters that's not coming to
xbox i don't like that game
you messy move it all y'all messy today
yeah hijacking this i don't like this
i don't like it anyway so i salute the
lady larry crazy his i love i love this
type of talk but i gotta i gotta get
into you know writing and um
just like kind of like how that passion
started for you you know you know what
is this journey how does this journey to
journalism kind of get you going where
did this come from
so it
actually kind of starts kind of sad
so
2016
i was kind
like i graduated high school in 2013
couldn't i find a job
like at all
and i i was depressed like
like i wouldn't go to family functions
or anything because every time they ask
me well what have you been doing all i
said was i'm looking for a job and after
a while it started to feel like
like not the people like not my parents
or my brother they never judged me for
it but it started to feel like people
would judge me
so
2016 in august
i was like well let me just start a blog
just to do something
so i started one blog which is more
political so
social issues stuff and then i started a
fashion and beauty blog
and then in 2017 well before that
happened 2016 in november my mom had a
heart attack um
sorry
oh she's
she's good now but like um on the way to
the hospital i was in the car and i was
like praying and one of the things i
said was like if my mom makes it like
i'll take my writing seriously i'll take
care of her she'll never have to want
for anything
and then
july 2017
unfortunately that article is no longer
up in july 2017 i was first published in
lap the brand which is naomi anderson's
website
so
that started and i was still doing my
blog at that point and then november
2017
i saw
before i became fandom wikia they had
their writers like contributor program
and i joined that
okay and i did that until 2019
and with
that program ended in
i was sad about that because i was like
well now i don't have any place to write
right and
but my editor from there i was like well
let me see where she's going
and she
was going to black girl nerds which is
where i've been writing ever since so
that very night that they announced the
program was ending i was sad about it i
reached out to black girl nerds and that
very night
i was on that writer's seat nice great
nice slow love how you transformed that
uh
you know that moment that i said
negative boom but something that was
really tough doing it during your time
and into something into a positive
energy and to focus it guys so you want
to say something one thing i wanted to
ask april you said you finished high
school and immediately you were looking
for a job so
did you
you you never it was never in the cards
for you to go to college you didn't want
to do that you just wanted to work
immediately kind of in the industry so
the thing with college i was accepted to
a few colleges but due to family she was
going at the time my family needed me at
home more than i needed to be at
university okay okay fair notice what's
up and um what i wanted to focus on is
one thing that i thought was really cool
was this you know a magic moment you had
and um
kind of talking about like
the most resilient women in gaming and
seeing like square enix kind of give you
your flowers with the uh kingdom hearts
and the aqua character and and seeing
them kind of retweet that and big you up
for that article like you know why why
does that mean so much to you
being a squareness fan since i was like
a kid like when my editor she messaged
me in like the slack channel for those
who know what slack is oh yeah i
remember
yeah
she messing me she was like oh my god
april they retweeted her article and i
went on there and i went and i ran and i
showed everybody and i was like look
lily's wearing this retweeted my article
that's what's up yeah that means a lot
i mean that means a lot to be
acknowledged by uh somebody or a company
that you deified
um
even if they put a like on your stuff or
or you know something's
something small like that
goes a long way
to the person that crafted that uh the
article the story the tweet or whatever
and
and i know that must have felt different
because it must have flashed you back to
i've been rocking with these dudes for
years
all the stuff that i can put into this
stuff did it make you go harder after
after they they looked at you and you
said oh my god this is the recognition
that i'm talking about did it make you
go harder in your craft
yeah stuff like that
like it made me so happy that it made me
want to like write more even more
and you know not only getting
recognition from square enix but i wrote
an article about my favorite
female wrestler naomi wwe
and she retweeted that article from
super black shout out to super black wow
and she follows me on twitter until this
day oh my god that's what's up
it's like
it's validation like you know you you go
through all these and you you you put
your heart and soul into the into this
into these works and you know what when
someone you know when you do a review
and a developer or publisher they hit
you it was like i liked your review it's
like yo like someone like someone's
watching it's why like we always say
like these people are watching don't let
you don't don't let
like that mindset oh you know no one
sees my stuff these people are watching
and and before you know you you'll do
something you'll think that oh you know
who's going to watch that and you'll
have the actual developers hit you it
was like i liked your review like that a
lot more of these people in these
companies watch these communities than
people think yeah they do and they
they're
the thing is
right if you writing from it just from
like just
for a work perspective of work right is
different than somebody who's writing
about it and it's the passion you can
see the passion right a true fan of it
and i'm sure that when they saw your
passion for the character for the
franchise that was the biggest thing
like for them obviously they want they
want people to speak about this stuff
fairly but they also do want people
talking about it that understand it
deeply and really care about these
characters and are able to sort of break
down you know what these characters mean
within the greater scope of the these
franchises and not everybody does that
sometimes you just have like you know a
piece that you did for work or whatever
a review or something like that that
isn't necessarily passionate but more
sort of objective quote unquote so
these subjective sort of takes on it is
is what really kind of
uplifts the entire franchise you know
yeah and it got his hand up on him
i like that zoom i like guys yeah i'm
feeling that this is nice
that's why
you know
you're seeing such a huge influence and
influencers
are are starting to get a lot more
access because it for years it was you
have to be media to do anything and now
you see a lot more influencers and the
media it's not necessarily that they're
not as important as they used to be
but now it's got to the point where it's
leveling the playing field where an
influencer can potentially get more
access to something because they have
passion towards that product and the
developer sees that then you know
sometimes you'll see an article on a
website that
it doesn't necessarily show or or you
listen to a video and you could tell
that person doesn't know anything
they're talking about and related to
this subject they're just doing it for a
job no that's a fact
and the thing too is what i like about
it is besides the aqua character like
you you talked you had like jade from
all the commenting
you had a lot of top 10 female resilient
characters in gaming it was just so cool
to see your passion there and i do want
to say awkward yeah
really bad
aqua had like a like a
she was a pretty dark character there at
the end man like you it was she she he
had ptsd
yeah
it's pretty much trapped in hell
that's why i got beef with mickey mouse
to this day
mickey literally mickey literally saw
her there before she got locked up and
then just forgot about her for like five
games
[ __ ] what's going on mickey mickey's old
and a lot of times he can't remember no
and kingdom hearts mickey's one of the
strongest characters
but his memory is not as strong
mickey mickey's body's strong his mind
is weak
[Laughter]
that
when you finally run into her like will
you go to save her she's like no one
came for me i've been left here this
entire time
and then she's like i saw you mickey oh
god in there
it was it was kind of like it was kind
of one of those things where she turned
it like she went to the dark side
because like that's the only thing she
could do to not go crazy
i understood
how did mickey see her though it wasn't
like a cut scene no mickey
no king king that's the worst part he
sent other people he didn't go himself
oh wow
he's like you i'm i'm letting my little
man's hand left
[Laughter]
gage he sent a 16 year old to
the funny thing is if someone else
wouldn't have showed up that person
would have been stuck there too
mickey ain't going his damn self like
why he's sending people he's looking for
the strongest why he ain't in the mix
[ __ ] said he ain't got time for like
because you have to have a certain a
certain ability to go in and out of
there
they never act like he has it but they
don't act like he doesn't either they're
like like he was literally
literally it's like
they did it they did a game called they
did
they did a game called birthplace uh uh
not birthday they did a game called
kingdom hearts 2.8 where it explains
aqua's version of what happens to
everything
and then literally like at the end of
that she gets trapped mickey clearly
sees someone helped him and then he's
like we're going to forget about her for
like 15 years wow
she's the only reason that like at the
end of the first one like there's these
big things that was about to kill you
and you never know how they didn't come
through the door the entire franchise
and that happened in the original
kingdom hearts well then when they did
2.8 like 10 years later you found out
she's the one that killed them to stop
them from killing them and then mickey's
like we're just going to leave her there
we ain't going to even act like she
exists lady break distance break this
down please nikki sending people to hell
break this down
you gotta help me through this you gotta
help me through like this is why you you
got that love for us if i would have
known this i would have had the same
amount of love for kingdom hearts if you
knew ricky was loose like
but we always knew it was something with
mickey she was just since that magic
way so vicky lyric yes mickey is so
powerful that in kingdom hearts 2 if you
died you had a chance of being turned
into mickey mouse to beat the last boss
like to beat the boss
with this game
mickey and the land of dragons came in
clutch
wow i can't
i can't with this i i didn't know that
of this it's absolutely this is great
lord this is great
well another thing i wanted to give you
your flowers with it so i really respect
you know your passion for female game
and amplifying black voices and our game
of girls of color in the realm so i want
to know like why does this resonate with
you so much and the the second part of
the question is um one of the things
also i want to give you flowers as well
is one of articles you did for us the
last game of that day it's one of your
first articles and it was kind of
talking about the tropes of the damsel
in distress you know what i'm saying so
let's start with the first part you know
a game of girls of color and then the
second part about the tropes of video
games you know peach save me i gotta be
i'm in the castle i need to help
you know that's it so break it down
bring it down white while these are so
passionate for these subjects
so
geeks of color which is
and then it's an account on twitter it's
like a whole organization
so i'm technically not a part of it but
i want to be
yo listen
get get get laid look down she's down
put the word out um
like i've pretty much been a geek my
entire life proudly been a geek my
entire life and i've also been in the
alternative community the rock community
and it's always been weird because
people would be like well
black girls can't be punk and i was like
black girls black girls don't like
gaming it's like well i do yeah i don't
know all of the women in my family
i'm still in it that's right
we're gonna talk we're gonna talk some
prince talk and some purple red because
i see some vibes
the whole damn zone distress thing came
about because of my love for kingdom
heart
first because
people are going to argue this but i
still maintain they do not treat kyrie
like a character kyrie is a plot point
sora only cares about kyrie when it's
the designated time to care about kyrie
okay okay and they were saying like in
kingdom rs3 she's gonna fight but she
got sidelined
right at the beginning
of the world
they literally had like a whole chapter
dedicated to making her stronger than
she didn't do anything like wow
wow girl like you know what's funny
a copy of characters fights more than
she does
right shion took her place as a guardian
of
wow continue
so you wanted to get you get that off
and and then tie that into to the
article with other examples of the
tropes
yeah so
the example of peach came about because
i do love peach and i like
that even though she is technically a
dance on distress she's still treated
like an actual character in a lot of
ways
you know she has her own
storyline and stuff and even in the more
modern games peach is treated like a
character with agency
which is what i wanted to highlight and
also highlight that there's not
technically anything wrong with having a
damsel in distress because some people
really do just want to be saved right
right yeah
what do you feel about so what's your
take on on more recent uh sort of
kind of protagonists and gaming female
protagonists like you know
like
ellie abby the gunk right are you
excited for first spoken like what what
kind of things what do you expect out of
these protagonists in these games
so
i was
i assume you mean ellie like the last of
us right there's a female protagonist in
general and protagonists of color as
well
so with protagonists of color it's
interesting to me to watch
like
the gaming community react to it because
a lot of times when you bring up like
you know we want characters of color we
want better representation and it's
weird when people say well there's no
reason it's like well people of color
exist
irregardless of reason like they just
exist they're people but you don't need
a reason to exist you don't need a
reason
for better hair styles for black people
i'll talk that talk right
right that's all girl
so it was always interesting to me to
hear people say well if you if you beg
for representation then it's going to be
meaningless like representation is
meaningful
in all forms yeah i i don't i don't
subscribe to that whole thought process
because
if one group is always being represented
and there's no representation for the
other groups you know um
and if you give them representation
these people will use those characters
and
i had the same problem really quickly in
uh fire team alien fire team
right so
when
yeah like when you get your character i
don't like the template yeah that you
get the character and you just put a
dark shade on the shade yeah you know
what i gotta call out a cent did that
too yes i was like damn what's going on
me and maddie was talking about i was
like yeah the representation like in the
hairstyles and uh yeah i'm sorry gives
you a moment yeah but it's just that
it's
it's it's kind of um dismissive yes yeah
in a sense because then
you're looking at my dollar like my
dollar doesn't matter
right but you're still clamoring for my
dollar but you don't give representation
to me in your product
so there lies the problem
if you want my dollar give me
representation in your product and that
representation has to be overt like it
has to be it i that's why i like the
gunk like when when somebody said they
didn't like the gun it was so many
different reasons why it remind me of
mario sunshine
uh uh uh a black female of color that's
handy capable right right if you really
start to break down the game
and her adventurous spirit inside the
game is so magnificent where
um you have this banter back and forth
and she's going into these dark areas
and she's learning in the world it's a
it's an exploration game as a puzzle
game it's a it's a platform it's so many
different games all rolled up into one
but the the shining beacon to it
it's
a female yes of color
and you didn't get you didn't take her
hair
and you didn't know they overtly make it
permed or something you just
kept it a little bit authentic and it
just felt really good playing the game
and i know that and
i'm not going to apologize for it
because i'm happy for it all right so it
meant it meant something to me to play
it and i don't like and i was just about
to do it i don't like
apologizing
or when we get a cookie you have to go
out it has they have to go out of the
way to do it so that it becomes the norm
it's a taut thing unfortunately that's
what it is it's a taught thing i
remember i remember uh you know ryan
mccaffrey talking about this like you
know what
the things that are happening in society
right now have taught have shown me that
i have to go out of my way to understand
something that i have not been taught i
haven't seen in my day-to-day life if i
don't do that i'm frauding because i'm
ex the expectation is oh you should know
this right and the fact is if you're
surrounded your life has you you've been
encompassed in situations that don't
introduce those things to you you're not
gonna know about it so to come out and
be like yo i don't know about this i
need to be taught about this to
understand what it is that you feel and
unders and understand so it is that
thing of
you when you say oh you're begging for
representation you're you know this is
uh what what the hell is it called
affirmative action or whatever the case
may be absolutely
it has to happen in order for people
who've never seen that to understand why
the playing field should be level and
again you you would wish that that
didn't need to exist but it does because
we have to get we have to normalize all
being the same and unfortunately that is
not the
case next talk about it yeah before i
give it back to lady lyric it was
i guess that's why for me i get so
excited for when i see
four spoken when i see
project midnight by compulsion right
because i'm like okay
you know we're gonna have a fema a
female black lead you know she's gonna
be in this era what is it all what does
that think it's like a new orleans what
was the um project midnight joyce off
it is kind of like a new orleans kind of
like uh it has a down south vibe yeah
yeah yeah you know what just looking at
the character reminding me of i don't
know if you guys ever played um
assassin's creed iii liberty
oh i love it i was the one that was on
the psp right yeah
yeah so that was very exciting to me
because abilene is a great character no
doubt no doubt but yeah i appreciate you
on that lady dirk because um again
seeing your your content
seeing how you always you push for that
that that's
almost like a mission statement for you
as well to kind of to bring awareness to
it and to see what that it means that
must you is so cool and i just love love
those articles and absolutely on that
because that was pretty dope
yeah i wanted like i'm the person that
will have the conversation that you
claim you want to have when people are
on twitter
and they're like well nobody will have
discovered i'll the person they'll sit
there and be like well explain it to me
then
and what's funny is when you finally
give them the chance they can't explain
it
like when the whole pewdiepie thing
happened i actually sat with a pewdiepie
fan it was like well he didn't mean it i
was like well
he said the n-word he was a grown man at
the time he knew what he was saying and
they were like well he's not like that
anymore and i was like well i'm i'll
check him out but to me
i feel like i cannot be a fan
for that reason okay no fair enough
absolutely you standing on your square
and having the tough conversations i did
hear you
have a conversation or it's a good
transition oh
blazing nitro
you know you you speak your mind you
speak your idea and i love it you're
passionate you're outspoken you know he
calls people out where they need to be
called out so i wonder transition then
in reference to would you ever get back
into consistent consecration on that
side with podcasting youtube twitch or
is it something right now where writing
is still like the number one passion and
number one focus because i think you're
super talented there too as well
yeah the the blazing nitro happened
because
i
firstly was supposed to be on soundcloud
but that never materialized and then
somebody
posted about anchor
and i was intrigued i was like well i
want to do this like i'll try anything
once yeah
so
[Laughter]
like you did say that you'll try
anything once come on king
ridiculous
i tried it and
it was fun and i still have some plans
that i would like to do with it i think
the first one was kind of
discombobulated because i didn't know
that you could stop recording so that's
why in certain parts they're like
silences or it's a little awkward the
second one was a full-out rant
because
for those of you who know about yandere
simulator and it's
dev alex mahan
he it was
was a 2020 like he had fully just pissed
me off and i oh yeah you went in and
you're just like
well and one of one of the things that
pissed me off is one i don't like people
that try to bully other people
and two i don't like people that claim
to be a creative or work in a field and
don't take criticism
and the way that he has a habit i don't
know if he does it anymore he's been
sort of quiet lately but like he had a
habit of sliding in people's dms
and going at them for criticizing or
trying to make their own game and at one
point he was like if you continue with
this project it could end my life and
that set me off wow
that's crazy wow yeah yeah i mean it's
you definitely
eloquently
put why that that thought process is
wrong and how people should
be able to take constructive criticism
right as long as we're not disrespectful
to each other right we should be able to
have those conversations and i thought
you put it very well you know and i
thought you started your square you were
very passionate about it and i agree
with it i agree with the sense that
at at any point we're not above
criticism and if you if you can't take
criticism especially in the games
business or as a creative then maybe
it's not the place for you not in
society today yeah society today has
allowed the participation trophy to
become a thing
um we don't no longer uh suffer
the
loss in the same manner right so very
early on you were always taught that
there's a winner and there's a loser
right
and now
there's a winner and a winner
there's no losers here
that fosters a false sense of security
in a child
so when they do grow up and they do get
um
constructively criticized
they're not used to that because they're
not told okay all right what you need to
do is you need to pick up your jab you
wouldn't have lost this fight if you did
this what they was telling them the
whole time is you're doing great you're
doing great you're doing great and doing
great doesn't help the person grow so i
can understand when when he said your
project
will end his life because
he
never encountered
the no
right he never encountered the criticism
he never encountered that whole thing so
that's a foreign uh feeling to him and
he's learning that to process that and
that's very hard for individuals now i
try to teach my children how i grew up
because children now
they're not all of them we want to
coddle them we want to um protect them
but we can't you know the world is cruel
and harsh and when you get on twitter
especially on twitter we can say some
evil things
sometimes i looked at my timeline like i
can't even believe that guys said that
and i have to block you now
yeah i am that's that's how i feel about
like
the
the crazy stuff people be saying on
twitter
it's like
you if you i feel like trying to
have an illusion a world where
everyone's always going to agree with
you and everyone's always going to you
know not say foul stuff with you
is in a realistic world and there are
some things where it's like block that
person like stop just sitting here
letting wander on your timeline over and
over again stop saying oh you know i
don't have you know i'm not gonna block
them because that lets them win like i'm
the kind of person where i mute you
before i block you yeah uh but it's just
like look like
i get it people shouldn't like i've
always been the kind of person where
it's like
i don't agree with the way he's handling
certain things on the internet but it's
just like you don't have to acknowledge
that power but continuously acting like
oh
you know we need to to combat this
because it's not a realistic thing like
there's going to be cyber bullying and
if you don't have the mentality to just
block it and move on and you're going to
let it dwindle in your mind for over and
over again for months and months you're
never gonna get nowhere like you gotta
have that's always tell people like oh i
wanna be you know
i could tell from like five minutes of
talking to someone i wanna be a content
creator i wanna get into this and i'm
like you're not going to be able to
handle the comments section you're not
going to like like she's shaking yeah
you agree
oh yeah i definitely agree like i've
been on
the internet since 2005 which i really
shouldn't have been because i was like
10.
whenever somebody brings up like old
youtube they're always talking about
2012 when i say old youtube i'm talking
2006.
back when the internet was the wild west
and you can say anything
right right after al gore made it mm-hmm
[Music]
[Laughter]
i invented the internet
you said you were zoned back then when
it was a wild west
yeah like
when people are like well
i don't i don't like credit like if it's
outright hate block like i'll creatively
block before you even get to me but like
if it's just outright criticism like i
don't think you did this writer i think
this didn't work the way you thought it
was gonna work or even if like
if you if you tell me something and it's
valid i don't care how you said it as
long as it's true i'll listen to it
right that's fair that's fair i i have
to disagree like
we can't
even if it's a valid criticism they say
mad disrespectful we can't let that fly
like this
yeah that's crazy
but she the the word she worded is like
you can be mad while however you say it
as long as you give me the opinion it's
like i'm not there's certain people in
this comment section that's not right
don't do that
it's because because if you try to come
at me disrespectful you getting sent to
block city
block city i always feel just the way
the way something is set criticism it's
fine you know it's okay later you're
about to say something good i'm sorry
well i was going to say like
if you're saying it's right but if it's
like wow disrespectful i'll fire back
and then block you
get
after all these years on twitter i don't
even fire back you go straight to yes
you straight you get you get muted
straight away like because it's just
like at this point some of these people
that's what they want yeah i mean they
want that that counter and the moment
you give them that energy they're gonna
be on your neck every time they possibly
can and it's just like nah like like i
ain't gonna block you unless like the
only time i blog people is if i see them
and i've muted them
because it's just like if i see you and
i muted you
i'm probably gonna block whoever
retweeted your nonsense or you can do
he's getting it too out of association
he could do like me and relentlessly
pound them into the on twitter
for that man
king they they they don't leave you
alone they don't ever
they don't know when i sleep so they're
like i would never think
hey go go go can go look at your twitter
and look at replies and quotes you be on
twitter too much man i'm out of that i
can't talk
listen i'm on twitter 24 7. i look at my
job
like the thing is like i'm done giving
them people that energy man like i'm
bothering me i don't i don't slaughter
all the generals i got all the knees
right this is the
the thing is though is that the generals
got foot soldiers and they go
extra generals they they don't have the
dexterity and this is see and this is
that's
i love it like i don't go for disparity
but they got the numbers man no no they
actually don't i if you look at my
timeline i'm pretty clean yeah even even
my girl told me last night she was like
they don't bother you know i said i
slaughtered them all yeah
i always king is the human filibuster
yes he
he is just he gonna keep going and even
if you can go toe-to-toe to him on
what's actually being said he's gonna
outlast you because that that's that's
what that's what gets whatever he tires
you know how you choose it you know i do
lean a little bit more attic's way in
the sense of how i run mine but again
king is for that like he he lives for
that this was made literally for me
because if i get one thing it could be
something
so ignorant and dumb
yeah if i get it
and i get a a
a rise out of you
i'm gonna hold it like a wild pit bull
and i'm gonna shake it till you pass out
at no point in time ha
listen i'm like a million and oh this
this is so much fun to me and i have fun
doing it because at certain and
you can see it as long as it's not
disrespectful yeah don't call me out my
name i won't call you out i don't we
don't do that we don't play that game
right as long as it's not disrespectful
i have mad fun with it because sometimes
people need an outlet if it's if it's
clean fun right and it's an outlet like
we have actual friends that we've met
through joking around so i come from
playing the dozens i come from standing
there snapping on people so
that stuff doesn't work
witty though but he's you can witty
though like you can drop in the mosh pit
that's fine that's all you you could
jump in the mosh pit with all the roof
raft that's cool
i'm gonna stay away from that because
in there is it is not good for my mental
health now i respect that and i'm
willing to i know me that's what i said
it's all about how you handle your own
account i am the same way like addict
like i don't have time to minute if i'm
arguing with you the only way i'm
arguing i must have already a lot of
respect for you to even engage in that
i'll i like you but there's dudes that
jump on and say something left i'm not
even giving that person energy that's
just how i because i can see if you
follow me first i
let's say that like you saying always
saying dumb stuff that like annoys me
but i'm sitting here like an unfollow
going cause beef so you getting muted
it's it's like you're gonna get muted so
you don't know i'm not seeing your
timeline because i don't want no beef
but i ain't gonna ever see your stuff
again
that's how you choose to run it's your
personal space
everybody runs it how they wanna run it
so it is what it is but we gotta move
forward like last summer i had to run in
with some taylor swift fans it was
overwhelming
the gangsters
they thought they had me but i was
sitting there eating my yogurt and
laughing at them
i want to get this last question though
because you kind of mentioned it before
and in reference to you know punk and a
little alternative and you know say i
want a shout out you had a really cool
article kind of like um things like 10
songs that kind of define
the generation and musically you know
what i mean you had my prince purple
right now i was very very happy to see
that you had i believe nirvana teen
spirit you had up on there you had trial
call quest scenario which was crazy
salute i even had to read the franklin
that respect let's go
so like talk about that it's like the
music and just your passion for it as
well because that's something else that
i feel you're doing in it you know let's
give me that night we got entertainment
secrets or anytime you wanna do that you
know just let me know
yeah my love for music goes all the way
i feel a little weird when i say i love
music because it feels like when people
go on food network and they say i've
been a fan of food my whole life
[Music]
like i always thought like when prince
died i took that like a family member
died like i came downstairs crying and
my mom was like what happened i was like
prince died she didn't even react she
was like i know i know
like i've been a fan of prince my whole
life like he died that i was already
mourning because chyna had died yeah the
wrestling yeah i remember
wait that i took that
do you use music as um because the way i
process music
when i hear certain tunes
like
okay you notice when i started today uh
i started in with three is the magic
number
right so um the correlation to that and
what i just recently just saw
transported me
back to when i was
eight
you know the seven to eight how old i
was but it took me back to eating a bowl
of cereal into my underoos
with my slip-on socks you know
in in the house
and you know um
so do you hear music and it transports
you back to a period of time because
that causality
it i can see why prince passing because
i felt the same way michael jackson
really tore me up a long period of time
um
because a lot of the music it's like i
grew up with him yes right so
um
that's how you process music in that
manner
yeah that's like
prince is one of my favorites kesha is
my favorite favorite favorite favorite
like like kesha is what i call the
soundtrack to my teenage years like i
would come home from school and put on
cat [ __ ] the entire summer i woke up in
the morning i put on cashier
and it was the same with prince like i
picked up a guitar because of prince oh
wow
self-taught
self-taught oh okay that's beautiful
that's what's up
i had to shout y'all
and i was i was a theater kid like every
talent show christmas show
mm-hmm
i love that i love that oh you're super
talented the amazing lady lyric hey i
love
and oh the name break that down real
quick
i got to get that
the science behind that
yeah lyric i love
so
it
i means love in japanese so it's
technically lyrics love love like double
love
but lyric i forgot how i came up with
that but i didn't want to use my real
name online gotcha even though it's not
hidden now because i'm a public figure
pretty much but it was
2010 and i was
on facebook and i didn't want to use my
real name so i put lyric i love
and it's like
i'm pretty much the only pers one of the
all right i think there's like one other
person online but i'm like pretty much
the only person with that full
moniker so if you type in lyric i love
i'll most likely pop up
yep yeah
fantastic algorithm let's go let's go
original original and of course we got
to ask you the question we asked all the
lords of the ladies in the round lady
lyric
what are your top five video games or
franchises of all time
so obviously kingdom hearts obviously
final fantasy mortal kombat
tekken
and the sims
oh
persona is up there but i haven't played
all of them so i can't really put it in
top five it's like six okay okay fair
enough fair enough right now and uh
favorite console of all time any
generation and why
yes play station two
the shooter said no it was the dreamcast
the dreamcast
we missed that whole part of the
comments all right
now of course you rock it out with us
it's all good we want you to watch that
guy if you got time or let me know how
you're doing on time
yeah i was thinking about it last night
because
i was watching or re-watching the xbox
documentary and when they brought up
like their first when they first
partnered up with dreamcast when they
migrated all the dreamcast games to the
xbox i was like yeah that's sort of when
sega fell off
we're going to get into that
whole lantern
fell off a cliff
so you want to get the chat i'll get the
poll while you go do the chats or yeah
get the poll first
so last week poll results are in and
people have spoken with the recent
impressive gameplay reveal of hellblade
2 at the game awards which xbox game
studio do you think is best when it
comes to pushing pure graphical fidelity
the winner of a very close four-way poll
at 37 of the vote
was ninja theory where the microsoft
budget is pure scary group coming in at
a razor close 32 percent
was the coalition never forget the gears
franchise and the matrix demo
and third place was the messy lord 16
i don't care y'all just fronting on the
power of minecraft and mojang
and then last place the 13th century
vote was playground games y'all must
have forgot forza horizon 5 is still
outside shout out to everybody who
rocked the vote um
do we agree ninja theory is the is the
new is the new thing
yeah i mean ninja theory for just pure
fidelity
what they're doing right now nobody else
is showing their hand in terms of what
what next gen looks like right in that
regard like even even playground
playground that's the old engine so the
next one is going to be running on
whatever forza motorsport is running on
yeah so that's going to be scary to look
at so you're going to look like that
so for me right now from what we've seen
is definitely ninja theory now what i
will say is this um whoever is able to
achieve that level of fidelity and more
of an open world setting is probably
going to win overall because the ninja
the ninja hellblade is not going to be
an open world game right it's going to
be a tight more cinematic experience um
but whoever hits that level fidelity
open world could be playground with
fable you never know um yeah it's gonna
be interesting to see but right now
definitely it's it's ninja theory no
doubt no doubt shout out to nina
christensen
the ceo over there okay you check my
interview up uh at largergamer.net yes
haha as soon as they got a question yeah
the key was yeah the king was there live
with that right so you want to get those
yeah no doubt so we got uh michael aka
best times finest uh check out your
outriders this update is great also
expeditions are super hard now yeah so
yeah outriders is back out there doing
this thing then we got the nightbeard
with the five dollar super chat
had a long day trucking in the snow
yesterday caught up on my iop backlog
thanks for the long shows and
entertainment happy holidays
yes sir keep your company on the road
warm on the road
we got the raiden blade two pound super
chat hello lords listening from work
have a great show
have a good shift sir appreciate it
and we got lognet's own flame remember
for 15 months
good afternoon realm it is really is it
really the final iop of the year bummer
where did the time go hope everyone has
a good show and a happy holiday you as
well we already know bro yes and we got
corey hell let's put the crest in the
chat member for one year just upgraded
to lord gold oh got that gold hook i go
beautiful thank you sir now though
then we got mr irishman
member for six months just sharing that
atlas is doing a survey asking what
products we would like to see from them
completed for my xbox sports knees are
on the line
you try to get some of these what you
doing try to get the votes up i like
that
change happening
how you how are you doing alexis how you
doing then we got played once again two
dollars super chat how is anyone
surprised that mickey being op i mean it
just kind of makes sense it just it's
weird it's not weird it's funny that
mickey's this mafioso
it's it's it's not o.p it's the fact
that he's sending people to hell
that's the problem i mean if you ask
most people that's probably what this d
represents to them oh my god
not me disney i want the bag
[Laughter]
then we got mad
mad 410 with the five dollar super chat
happy holidays louis to you as well sir
then we have hargie cheney five dollar
super chat the gunk was the right game
after halo a chill game after the
fast-paced halo colt convinced me to
play it with his enthusiastic praise
doubts yeah they gotta clear the gunk
then we have scrub nurse member for 19
months thank you sir
shout out to the lords in the chat happy
holidays enjoy your family your games
and some free time from the daily grind
a safe holiday to all to you as well
thank you thank you
then we have hard to find two dollars
super chat send the haters to hell like
mickey the goddess
[Laughter]
shout out to mickey
[Laughter]
goofy take care of them
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
dollar super chat finally sam fisher is
back talk about it hashtag a-h-t-l-i-o-p
um
yeah we're gonna talk about that we're
gonna talk about that
we got the dutch rudder two dollars
super chat my fins are made but we
trashing the jets today
that's not even funny
[Laughter]
we got dragon heart yobe member for six
months shout out to sir
uh hashtag peace love life to the iop
continue the great work gems congrats
cog you making waves king i think
starting next year when you take knees
they gotta scan them and send them in
the form of trophy
i i i don't wan i want their needs to be
converted to bitcoin
ethereum knees
that's what i need i need bitcoin knees
wow i don't want to read this one but
i'm going to read it hold on
i'm curious i'm curious how much one
knee is in bitcoin
i want a full coin
now what happens what happens if it's a
smaller person like is it half that 40
wow we're not gonna go at the shame in
little people
so
so like someone someone like you know as
big as someone like me and then someone
that's a smaller size like my kind of
sage upstairs
i don't know about that man
if they don't have the shea butter on
their knees i don't want those knees
them up and send them back pause
there we have um
let me play with your joystick
[Laughter]
[Music]
this one
[Music]
[Laughter]
y'all need melinda jerkson on yes
melinda jackson the actor the actress
behind the behind senua yes that would
be amazing to have her on oh daddy we
need to we need to try to reach out to
more like voice actors in general [ __ ]
yeah yeah tracks and we have a spartan
ghost worked well for us when we had
some of the
you know the the what is it that the
motion capture people we'll reach back
out to them yeah yeah
yeah they got all hollywood on us
[Music]
spartan ghost two pal super chat they
made for spoken racially ambiguous
because of sales
i mean i don't know this is really
ambiguous
he's not ambiguous
when it comes to first spoken i just got
to like see more of that plot because
like every time like i get so confused
when they talk about for spoken i'm like
is she in the past is she going to pass
to the present are they trying to
kingdom hearts my ass like what's going
on in this game like
ridiculous
and then we have um
lord meyerhoof with the five dollar
super chat you all sleeping on ray
tracing minecraft hashtag messy without
sleeping on it it does look amazing what
is it
it's not sunny it's not sticking with
saga you know the third place they beat
out playground
in the poll
then we got flame five dollar super chat
why do i have a feeling people are
making those types of names just for
saab to read them in this suave i agree
i agree it does it does seem like
there's a master plan behind flame the
moment you just said that everything
more people are going to do that here we
go the people that didn't have that
thought process now next week
i'm gonna have a whole lot of pausing
going on let's get it so we are on court
yeah yeah oh let me get one merch on
shout out oh
x2
yeah what a hoodie
zip hoodie iop love you bro love you too
bro i missed playing with you i know i
got being you have not connected
i still haven't received my all natties
what's up oh really really yeah we gotta
talk about that
we're gonna we're gonna have to tell you
what we tell everyone else that that's
just teespring man i gotta see the
receipts that i was saying
they take a bite
a lot of roughness five pounds super
chat your iron lords podcast is like an
event i look forward to every week but
shout out to your podcast the sunday
after xbox bought bethesda
for the longest time that was our
biggest show was that show
the classroom
flame two dollars which i cannot confirm
nor deny that that was my intent addict
yes
good to see you good to see you my my my
brother from the premium experience by a
seller brother
yes yes we'll be doing that premium
packs experience always always
anyway but let's get into it y'all so uh
split a cell remake and so uh we'll read
the article from ubisoft they've green
light the development of a splitter cell
remake that will draw from the rich
canvas of the brand led by ubisoft
toronto the game will be rebuilt from
the ground up using snow the snowdrop
engine the same engine may use on um
avatar upcoming and also the uh upcoming
star wars game as well as i believe that
division two uses it as well to deliver
next generation visuals and gameplay and
the dynamic lighting and shadow the
series is known for so let's get right
into it let's start with lady lyric
splinter cell remake any interest what
was your feeling on this news
so i had i expected a splinter cell
remake in a way like
the game was like huge in the 2000s
definitely definitely definite
so it didn't surprise me but
it's the studio okay okay just you look
concerned look
a little concern
somebody brought up a good point where
it's like okay splinter cell is
announced so we're just gonna forget
everything that happened
so they can't woo you with this they're
not gonna make you erase all the bad
memories or any negative press this
doesn't just doesn't wash this away
lately i i wish activision blizzard a
very merry get better work culture
fair enough and speaking in the back
door it looks like my brother lord fans
from games talk live lord fans are you
there let me get you levels sir
see i saw you but he may be dropped out
maybe coming back we'll be coming back
but anyway let's get a little pd man so
what where are we at with this whole
splinter cell remake are you excited are
you pumped wait what'd you feel it
how how can you not be pumped at least
seeing another sponge cell coming out
like how can you not like i'm excited to
see
uh you know them bringing back the
original remaking it and it's gonna be
nice to have one um i wish it was a new
one uh but you know at least you know
we'll get a little something from it
oh no doubt that's what's up
lord
a rally are you there might check sir uh
can you hear me yeah they go that's
about y'all there we go all right there
there we go there's the bay area that's
what i'm talking about let's go here we
go what's happening
yeah so splinter cell huh yeah
um you know it's a franchise a lot of
people have been waiting for to come
back
um i think it's about time
uh i think they just need to bring it up
to date you know with the mechanics and
stuff make sure it feels good
with this remake because
this is obviously like a jumping off
process like a reboot if you will yeah
and i i think that's that's what's
needed right now
now do we know if it's just going to be
a remake of the original game or are
they going to kind of combine some of
the you know so it's left that they did
it's looking like just a remake of the
original part one that's what it's
looking at yeah
yeah yeah so i mean like i like i said a
lot of people are waiting for this game
this is uh this should be something that
uh a lot of people are going to be
looking forward to and playing uh you
know i i i personally like the splinter
cell series and i'm not too big on
stealth but splinter cell was different
there was something about it that that
captivated me
and that made me want to play through
those games um
i think it's just the way they handled
everything it just seemed more
like there was always a serious tone to
the games sam fisher was like an older
dude
and like just i mean like it was just
such a good franchise man i can't wait
to jump back into that i'll definitely
be picking up that remake no doubt no
doubt lord addict don't know what your
love is for the uh split itself
franchise how you feeling about this
news
i love this splinter cell franchise i'm
more like on pd where i wish it was like
a newer one
um i have to see exactly how ubisoft
handles this like i actually
as much as i don't like the way they did
with the assassin's creed i do enjoy the
new assassin's creeds i just don't feel
like they're assassin's creed games
i just got to see
where splinter cell fits with ubisoft
these days like if they try to take
splinter cell in weird directions that's
going to be weird uh i do feel like
they could make it work because
regardless what it's a lot of people i
do feel like they still make great games
it's just
it's not the type of games that we used
to like we're used to a lot of different
types of games from ubisoft and that's
just not that company anymore
and i got to see exactly what their
future
what
the splinter cell brand is and how they
try to make the franchise going forward
uh you know apparently they're this
nft's things too like they try they're
trying to do some stuff with that
putting yourself in there and getting
the rock off
i am all right
here we go get my money yeah good lord
that afternoon
[Music]
[Laughter]
so that's just where i stand right now i
got i'm not against it i just got to see
what they do okay fair enough now this
is the one i want to know what he
thought about
lord solve lord
murk and murder himself we've been yeah
we're just feeling about this
this is
i'm i'm excited for it i'm i was
i kind of fell off my chair when it when
they finally announced it although i
didn't necessarily appreciate how they
announced it because i mean you had the
game awards right there like yeah
why
why not i mean if we talk about what one
more things might have gotten a pop that
gets a pop you know instead
because i think what it is well it's not
even that i think that
you know
do you miss after ever do anything at
the video game awards no not really
maybe maybe
maybe there's like something like loki
was the last time they announced
anything at the game awards yeah that's
true that's true and it could be maybe
if it's not that maybe it's one of those
things where it's like
keeley's not gonna want to show
something on a like a like just a logo
on the screen right and maybe like
because of the pandemic they don't
necessarily have anything to show us and
i prefer them do this then hype up some
vertical slice that we're never going
gonna see so
yeah but it just you know what it is it
feels so low-key
that like you said attic i wonder what
their true dedication to this is
so and that just has me a little bit
worried about how they announced it but
the fact that it's coming back is super
exciting to me for me splendisol
was that second moment
on xbox that really made me be like wow
wait a minute this is on another level
like when when i first played halo that
was a moment right
but when that splinter cell came out
and it the talk was all about the
lighting and how
light and shadow in real time mattered
and you can literally slip into the
shadows and the the thing was we had
seen all of this before in metal gear
and we had seen it in tenchu
but
the difference there is that it was more
pre-canned this was the light literally
you could have made it bro yeah the
meter and you could change the dynamics
of the lighting yourself so you could if
there was a place that was well lit you
could do what you needed to do to darken
that area to move around the lights out
right so it was like it was very dynamic
in that way and it was just different
because it was all about being
methodical it wasn't about when you look
at solid snake
it was it was more action-oriented
ultimately you'd always get into an
engagement whereas with sam fisher you
could literally ghost the whole the
entire game and that was a real option
right yeah so for me that that's what
made that game so special it was a it
was a second o ish moment for me on xbox
and since then i love that franchise so
hearing that it's coming back these are
the things that i want to see because
the initial sort of
the initial sort of rumors were that it
was coming back and it was going to be
more open world and i don't think that
isn't the case anymore like i think i
think that is still the case to a
certain extent i think they're going to
take
what i hope this is is a final financial
seven remake type of situation where
they're taking
where they're taking the the sort of
core of that game and expanding it
well it came out
other places
[Laughter]
yeah you mean it came out on every
platform but uh expo it wasn't
it wasn't complete
exclusively not on xbox
exclusively not complete i gotta get hey
you gotta got his head up i love this i
love that all right all right go ahead
i'll continue
i forgot
you just gonna get on the show
put your head there yeah yeah i forgot
so um
so for me what i need to see what i want
to see from a spooner cell coming back
right i'm just happy he's coming back
but what i would like to see is for them
to take
the core tenants of splendisol one two
three okay incorporate that into this
game with the overall shell of splinter
so one right and expand out upon it a
little bit with that open worldness
because i think to me
there's a lot you can do there in terms
of
like halo halo is old-school halo when
you get into certain engagements in
smaller areas or whatever and then the
open world is something different that
leads up to it i think the same thing
can be applied to a splinter cell game
where it's like okay make
infiltrating the specific area where
you're going to part of the gameplay and
then once they get into where they where
he needs to infiltrate
then it's classic splinter cell gameplay
okay and i think that's how you sort of
evolve what splinter cell is yeah
in addition to that
in addition to that i don't know if they
if this is the starting point for
splinter cell coming back do you think
it's a jump off not just a one-off then
uh people gonna hate me for this uh-oh
but i don't think ironside should come
back oh come on what's up you violent i
don't if it's a jumping-off point have
you listened to michael ironside lately
right right no
no no the ball he just has a lot of
health problems
right he's
yeah he's okay with recasting the voice
yeah i would i i would like someone
similar in tone because obviously the
blacklist actor was not at all similar
in tone didn't they do i would like that
kiefer come in for well
keefer came in no keeper came in for
solid snake for for snake oh okay metal
gets all at five
i can assure you there's plenty of
people out there that sound identical to
that man so
yeah so so to me that's
that's the only thing but to me i just
worry about what ubisoft is going to do
with this like addict said they still
make great games people could say what
they want about the changes that they've
made the sort of uh you know game is the
service stuff that they're trying to do
but at the core of it like you look at
valhalla
you know just i just want the realm to
mark this day down
uh december the 19th 2021
where saul is about to be let down and
accomplish
i it exactly you know i worry i like
like like lady lyrics said i worry about
you
[Laughter]
in that regard
so i mean i hope they don't do me dirty
i don't know that they won't um i'm just
glass and fish is coming back and it's
and it's it's with a team and people
that have
done this before and care about that
franchise so my hope is that they are
able to bring it forward in a way that
that kind of brings the character back
big time we'll see no doubt let's hear
from the king he clearly
likes the direction you'll be going
lately so i want to know where he feels
about the bag he wants that bag okay so
um
it's it's funny
that
if it sounds too good to be true it is
right
they were going through a lot of trouble
so what they did they threw a dollar on
the floor look at dolla
you gotta dial off the floor like oh man
wait a second um
all serious king like are they going
through trouble every assassin's creed
sells more than the previous not talking
about that
kind of the court of public opinion i'm
not talking about that i'm not talking
about their games i'm talking about they
have a lot more problems than just the
games
you know
that's what so
if it's a smoke screen
let me shut them up
how many times
y'all fall for the banana in the
tailpipe all the time and y'all just
look over like how did it fall for that
um
a game that's announced he said it
wasn't at the game award show of course
it wasn't at the game awards show
because it just came out with it yeah
let's stop the bleeding
this is a stop this is a classic stop
the bleeding situation all right so this
is what y'all all been clamoring for
what do we have in the background we can
shut up can't say another size of creed
we already you know hey yeah we just
about to drop the dlc don't care for
that oh that's saying fishes don't get
them that got them though they'll get
crazy over this we get crazy light off
of this they'll forget about the nfts
and all that
um
and y'all did
like literally y'all like yo i don't
know what they're gonna do with the
ironside if they should bring them back
you literally forgot about all the other
stuff and just sat there with this stuff
all right
i see the banana tailpipe let's let's
this is not even white boarded yet
of course they're going to use the
snowdrop engine
right so let's go into exactly what
you're going to get right so spies
versus mercs look into it in a giant
world in a separate like uh thing like
division
i think it's going to play just like how
the division plays
um on max settings with our consoles
that we have currently now
so the tools the beast
our um the tool sets will be far enough
along that we can have the next
generation well current generation uh
graphics gameplay stuff like that they
will bring the game up to snuff for all
the quality of life stuff that we're
used to now
um
i feel that
it should run the way
resonate evil two
uh took the remake um
and because i i've never played final
fantasy vii that game didn't come out
yet
it's out of place i did play that was
masterfully done npc yeah i i i
um
and that's what i wish i could have that
mentality just just acknowledge nothing
exists unless it's on game fast listen
phil dominance maximus are really
expensive just brought me mortal kombat
11. i did not have to pay a nickel all
right yeah i'm i'm at a point right now
with finally the hell did i get here
it just came out
all right i'm gonna download it we'll
play something all right thank you
please do you know marketing teams would
love everyone having kings oh
marketing dream
forget it anyway it's the truth i don't
care
i got so much stuff to play everything
is new to me anyway um so
they can do the the
remake
in the the way the resident evil was
done i thought that was done masterful
it told the same story but it told it in
a manner that felt new fresh and
invigorating to the to the franchise i
think that's what sam needs going
forward i don't think they need to do
something like uh assassin creed
where you have different objectives on
the map and then you go into this area
and then you it turns into a sneaking
mission
um
because
and i say this for this okay there's two
other games that's coming out that is
going to have these same mechanics and
they won't use that same formula so they
will be more successful in the whole
sneaking genre where
you say metal gear remake for the
playstation 5 that we're going to keep
on acting like doesn't exist that does
exist and when it does show up you guys
are going to act like you're super
surprised we know it's coming and we
know that perfect dark is coming and
it's going to lean in that same area so
i think we're going into a revolution
back into the sneaking genres back when
that used to be a thing uh like origami
2 that we just got inside game pass the
other day um
anytime you see this on my neck game
passing will be talked about a lot um
but it's it's the fact that
we're we have to bring this generation
back to that so we can get 10 shoes and
stuff like that those games back so yes
it
recasts ironside um he he has yes no but
it's not this he has a lot of health
issues so let's get a new actor going
forth that we're going to have years
ahead because they want to turn this
into another pillar uh like assassin's
creed you know um and that's my hope
anyway yeah could you imagine
spies versus mercs right in a division
type of um dark side like you know um
what what's that when you go to the um
yeah could you imagine it like that and
then you pick what side that you're on
and you have like fraction battles
that stuff can really work and yeah
back to the monetization i'm about to
ask you now let's get to it financially
this is a windfall for them the the
level of skins that they can sell you
they they've done it to me in a second
like the reason why i know you're like
yo we falling for the banana in the
tailpipe but the reality is they have
been so resistant to bringing it back
they've been clowning and trolling their
base for so long they've been putting
him in mobile games and it to the point
like where they don't feel like it was
ever gonna come back and i guess the
reason why we thought it was never gonna
come back because how do you really
monetize just a single player version of
the og xbox game remade i guess that's
the question where it's like like so you
think my question to you is do you think
that it will they will force the um
spies mercs component to try to get that
because otherwise ubisoft can't really
mine
you need a multiplayer component to it
see halos just showed you they can you
can
um successfully
launch two components to the same game
right and give you exactly
both crowds make them happy right right
so
you have the campaign dudes that are are
crazy happy right now and when co-op
launches later they'll be infinitely
more happy but the multiplayer dudes are
in the same space they're happy as hell
so you can do this and it's can be
successful so looking at that and this
is white boarded right now so yes
earlier halo has monetized
all types of skins except from the guns
to the to
the windshields on your wall
right
so
when ubisoft sees that
they say man hell yeah we have a service
we can do all of that stuff that they're
doing and they're making money hand over
fists with assassin's creed i can see
this happening but again
like you said they were trolling their
fan base
to the point where
you thought it was never coming out it
had to take something that was a little
catastrophic in the ecosystem
in the dna of their brand
to make them throw this out i got you so
basically what's been going on studio
culture and everything okay
i'll jump in um yeah i'm kind of with
solver i am i was hyped for this you
know i'm very i was surprised definitely
high for i'm glad
it's a it's a remake though you know
because i it's been long enough
and i don't really know i'm with fawns
like
i've always liked spinning cello i would
say something black i have like saying
fish are better than snake y'all
kojima got the cinematic flair and i get
it over the tops that i get but would it
come to what's that that pure stealth
genre and like saul said like that was
the first game i see where
light and dark was a mechanic you had a
meter when you go into dark areas it it
lets you know and then remember like you
do to jump up on the wall with the split
with the split you know
drop down on yeah i remember the little
mechanics you go to a door you put the
snake camera underneath the door to see
what's going on on the other side like
remember that time he took the knife and
he cut the claw and he cut the claw off
that wasn't cake that was chaos theory
that wasn't it that was chaos theory
oh my god inside i said
bro it was it was crazy and then the
thing is like
come on when you that oh when you when
you when the spots versus mercy oh you
go
you say yeah your mama don't love you
yeah i guess i guess at the end of the
day you
i guess at the end of the day
i get it you know maybe a better studio
could have been making it but at the end
of the day like it's like
i'd rather a realm where splinter cell
might flop but it exists then around
where it doesn't exist
like even like you said king like you
grab them up put the toast to their head
you know what i said and then you drag
them that's when xbox live that's what
xbox live got real
the
the
the crossover because i remember when a
dude grabbed me up from behind
i don't i i don't necessarily agree with
addict in that uh you know you'd rather
it exist at all because you can tarnish
the brand
if you come out with something wow i
mean what what's what's what's the point
so okay i know that you can say if it's
terrible then it's like you know it
makes people think of splinter cell in a
bad light especially you know the
newcomers and but but the young cats you
know
they don't know what splinter cell was
so if all they have is this remaster and
they're like this is whack like yeah
let me ask you a question fawns like
what do they know now nothing because it
doesn't exist like
so so if they never make it and they
never make another splinter so why does
it matter because they would never know
the game the thing is when when we are
talking about splinter cell and they
hear us talking about they're like oh
that's whack that game sucks no we're
talking about the old splinter cell
and that's fine but that they can never
it's just that those experiences i can't
go back
i
people like my brother they're not going
back and playing those old xbox games
they might not be playing
games either that's my point
what you want so you don't want them to
make it because they might no
no no no no i do but you said even if
it's bad you'd rather have it in this no
i said i said i'd rather have a realm of
possibility where the game could be bad
then the alternate version of the one
warrior now where they don't make the
game ever went off yeah for a one-off
i'll agree you know if if if it's whack
and it's it's one game
oh my god
i'm putting that energy on my game i
mean like it looks like
all right
look at it from a standpoint of god of
war they didn't do anything with that
brand for a while if they never would
have tried anything else we wouldn't not
getting true we would have gone 100
if they would have just kept that but
like you know that's that's an older
game we did what we wanted to do we're
going to keep it in the past right we
never would have got to stand right now
both of y'all right in the sense though
but let's be real at it let's say
playground now
and they drop that fable and that fable
is whack
that's right
the thing is
oh
i would rather
fable come out
and be a possibility that it's not a
good game then microsoft just vaulting
fable nevermind i never make it okay
at least they just took the shot
what you're saying is that you you want
them you want them to take the risk
right
that's what i'm saying like to me it's
like makes sense if you're going to have
like the mindset we might make an
underwhelming game to the fans so we're
not going to make it ever
i don't like that because then they're
never going to try that franchise again
like like to me it's like the god of
wars you know
that i hated that right like hey
like
if you would have had like that kind of
mindset too like after halo reach
microsoft's like yo we did this
what can we do we lost the developer
so let's just do something different
let's let's vault halo never tried again
halo infinite would have been have this
restructure in 2021 they would have just
let that in the past and a lot of people
probably would have wanted that right
but it's like to me it's like i want
these developers risking it for the
biscuit the not responsibilities
for the business let me finish my okay
i i think what worries me about this
coming back is that when you look at
blacklist right blacklist is the game
that tried to appease everyone it tried
to give you different ways of of
engaging
and if you can engage in a more action
type way or you could go pure stuff they
gave you the whole gamut of how to play
that game that game in a lot of ways
felt more like an immersive sim right
like if you look at an arcane game like
okay tackle this however you want and i
to me in a lot of ways that make that
splendor show at its best
when you look at those type of games and
how they do and you even look at arcane
and what they had to do to sort of
to to make their games feel more
appealing to the mainstream and death
loop don't tell maddie
yeah right so and i get what maddie's
saying i i i like that more than here
but it worries me that they're to look
at that and be like okay we can't give
them pure stuff it has to be this right
this amalgam yeah i would agree
i will graveyard on that like you know
definitely because i i talked to maddie
for like an hour and a half one day
over that it's like because because
maddie kind of wants more of like the
structure from dishonored and absolute
but it's not called it's not dishonored
three it's called definitely
so it's just like and i understand that
you want a remnants of previous games
that you love the fran of that developer
for but once again if you put them in
that box they're never gonna open the
door they're always gonna make games
similar to dishonored and at that point
we can't say we want newer experiences
when you want them to relive the older
experiences newer games yeah i mean look
the thing for me why i'm so happy about
it because again even though i know what
king's saying what they just giving the
band look i'm glad let them hit rock
bottom again let them continue
so i can get what i want because i'm
selfish
so for me i'm like look
they were worried that they can monetize
let's be real in my opinion they were
worried they could monetize a
single-player stealth game and that's
probably why this thing took so long for
it to come out you know so this this is
still for me
shout out to michael einstein we
apologize for all the disrespect in the
realm i want you back don't listen to me
love you but
we want you back you rock it to the
wheels fall off brother we we like that
voice what's up um i will say this
yeah to the wheels forward
to the wheels yeah i mean
have you heard the thing is
he has like copd like he doesn't like
people
the way you talking is like you don't
want you know what it reminds me of when
transformers came out the movie fawns
remember yeah and they was like nah
we're not gonna use frank walker for
megatron we're gonna use hugo weaving no
i want megatron from g1 decepticons
attack i want that rocket to the wheels
for that's the dude that's been known
for getting with flowers let me ask you
this
how would you feel if they would have
changed actors and and didn't use steve
downes for masterpiece exactly yeah he
owned him but i think i think that i
think that's different in terms of like
franchise from installment to
installment like
i like when i was talking about like the
dishonor to death like those are two
different games so i want them to feel
different but played similarly like
because clearly they're an arcade game
but like when it comes to
halo when it comes to like previous
nostalgia games unless something happens
to that man where he passes away or
something here use that dude like
because it's just like i can understand
already
he just i mean i'm just saying you need
you really need to listen to him
he sounds so gravely like soul grappling
apologies to the lords of disrespect and
real quick you mentioned the
transformers uh r.i.p to the creator of
yeah henry ornstein passed away
rest in peace recipes for sure um yeah i
was gonna say that and i will say this
though king would find this interesting
ton if y'all watch the video of the
announcement
tons of xbox references
tons of you know we got a fake xbox they
want that on game pass and if it wasn't
for them they took a shot on us and it
was high cutting edge tech at the time
on the og xbox and i just found it
interesting i mean i'm not saying this
yo that's banana in the table listen i'm
not falling for none of these jets
none of them they can sit there juke and
jake all day long they can do crossovers
i'm just gonna stand there in my own
folded until you present something
that's actually tangible i don't trust
you because you have been dismissive
with this franchise for so long and it's
just really funny that right now is the
time that you put it out when you are in
on the brink of some type of weird ruin
i don't care no
the chat mentioned something that i that
i thought about myself um if it was
going to be a reboot but with a brand
new character
his his daughter
no
no no i'm just saying is something that
crossed my mind
i don't
it's something that crossed my mind but
i'm
there's not five people though that's
the same thing
i can't do that no we ain't doing that
get them england let's get them get it
all right all right so
imagine them taking one of your favorite
characters what are your female
characters one of your pillars that
remember the girl they locked in hell
naturally they take the girl they locked
in hell and just said you know what for
just shake shake let's uh she had a son
and we're gonna just replace her with
him
no we ain't gonna do that mickey mickey
didn't lock him in hello
your thoughts
um
i get what you say like you don't want
somebody to fridge a character just
because like they could also have it
where it's like a leon s kennedy at a
wong situation or if they did want to
incorporate the daughter they could
incorporate her you could do that as her
own
side of the story okay okay
i don't like i feel like
kind of like i feel like they're dealing
with god of war where his son is being
like bred into the god of war franchise
so
you know
kind of like that because you could
clearly see that they're setting up for
him to take over the reigns
sometime in the future
that is i mean they said this is they
said this is the last one yeah and throw
it away
away yeah they said that there's so
there's no there's no trouble we're
gonna go back to what was really rocking
and throw this away um and get a jump
button if you if you think if you think
that they're going back to that i i i i
got stuff and when it happens you're
gonna look over to me and you'll be like
i can't stand this
so you so so hold on hold on hold on
hold on
so you're saying they're gonna go back
to the old ways again successful stuff
the stuff that launched it off
the stuff that was really good
didn't god award 2018 sell more than all
the other three combined
the other three didn't come out that
don't matter it's just a lot of dudes
he just hijacked my whole thing i put my
hand up and everything i was being so
nice
anyway i just finished look this is an
easy it's an easy one it's just like
it's the easy w excitement you really
it's gonna be hard for them in my
opinion to mess this up because you
literally got the core team and you just
okay so remake right so we are not going
to get rid of sam fisher for remake's
sake
right no no thank you i don't think
they're doing that no one no no no i'm
just i'm just telling someone stop it
[Laughter]
but i do agree with him and the fact
that last last point is that i think it
could if this
does well which it should
this could be a jumping off point to
show interest in the character the
series that they was worried about right
if they could they could have a possible
mass effect trilogy moment how mass
effect messing up you know what i'm drop
drama and all that stuff they go back
they remake you know remastered the the
core game that you know everybody love
and that can generate interest so we'll
see what happens i thought people like
blacklist uh
people oh yeah they like blacklist but
it's not as pure of a stealth game as
the other ones same way that people i
love conviction i like what conviction
did but a lot of people was like oh you
know he's murdering too many people who
are you know
the thing is
i feel like they'll go towards more
convention in the gameplay than they
will anything else i don't i don't think
you're gonna get that core sam fisher
like that core core
gameplay but they're not trying to
demographic us man right they're worried
about it selling to the modern audience
yeah that's what they hit rock
king got his hand up this last enemy hey
hey addict
so if that's this new game ourselves all
the other games combined
so are we talking is it
are we talking about hold on are we
talking about splinter cells or are we
talking about this i'm just i'm just
cracking wise
crack wise but you have nothing to do
okay okay moving on
moving on moving on so we gotta get this
cuz i love you sorry guys
yeah yeah i got him hold on a second let
me scroll back a little bit but yeah i
got this popping going down and we get
into this
power on situation
okay yes
we got your joint
we got gaming forte remember for 25
months thank you my brother that's a
beautiful thing beautiful thing look at
that beautiful shield lords man i'm in
love thank
thanks to you for two years of
entertainment thank you brother
appreciate the support talking with us
bro
then we got relish gt five dollar super
chat did y'all see infamous three at the
game awards it was based in the desert
and looks way better a reskin for spoken
that is not a new game not a new ip wow
wow they called it
wow
then we got q-tang clan with the ten
dollars
thank you iron lords for a great year of
content it is always a pleasure watching
the lords get together can i get a soul
gt7 is not looking good even after
asking for help from xbox turned in
iop book effects when did that happen
please please guys my wheels
wow yeah i didn't haven't heard that one
that would have been front page news if
that happened please please my wheels
aren't looking right
there we have once again
let me play with your joystick five
dollars
the two smoothest voices in gaming
podcasts
i loved i'd love to share the sticks
with those oh yo yeah
you
[Laughter]
oh
we got mr joanna dark five dollar super
chat hello lords would like to would you
like to splinter cell remake to give us
a younger sam fisher or like hawkeye
with kate bishop trained his daughter
pastor baton no
[Laughter]
let my man rock stop playing
then we got pixel bit g remember for 25
months as well thank you so much sir
bless us we got happy holidays lords and
much continued success to you in the
year to come you as well
why nobody wants sam fisher to get his
rocks off what's going on here man
trying to replace him they just try to
get him out
i just got to say that that little
jingle that you played there reminds me
of like the gong show yes yeah i like
the other one when he played the other
one the one he did on colt by mistake
that's my joy
all right there we go mr joanna dark
five dollar super chat should michael
ironside return to voice sam fisher or
should we get a new voice setting the
franchise up for the future question
question question happy holidays happy
holidays yeah you could get uh gaz on
daily for that yeah yeah he'd have
he'd play a good sam fisher right yeah
that would be hilarious
splinter cell is the game that made me
an xbox fan i think that happened for a
lot of people as well yeah it's a little
classic
and we have don otaku five dollar super
chat triple a ubisoft is hit or miss
sometimes but they're games like mario
rabbids uh starlink with star fox and
child of light and valiant hearts are
goaded yeah those are smaller games but
i mean that's the thing people you can
say what you want about ubisoft and and
the way they make games and what they've
been trying to do with continuing to try
to monetize their games at any uh
any way possible but at the end of the
day the product still plays well looks
good like
yeah i don't know maybe i'm in the
minority but i i like a lot of ubisoft
games yeah man like look valhalla holla
has bloated his head but that game did
it come out
valhalla valhalla that's not in game
passes
sir
[Music]
super chat
i can see you we saw putting different
color goggles on for sam as nft yeah the
great like the great that the great
chris reagan once said no game no hype
shout out to chris that's the christian
reagan wait hold on king
is ac odyssey has it ever been in game
pass
i brought that i wrote that
okay
no no i told you i'm selective with
myself listen
you don't control me
but there's game pass
actually i i have dipped my toes outside
the game pass pool
[Music]
then we got pillsbury 27 with the ten
dollars which i like that
it's about time and next year it's the
20th anniversary of splinter cell and it
was on the original xbox ubisoft better
not bring micro transactions loot boxes
and cosmetics happy holidays yeah
they're not coming next year either so
you see you and when wolf rooms come out
yeah that's that's like four years
minimum it's going to come out with
wolverine together they're going to
launch together
20 28.
for all y'all that are not aware pretty
much all the splinter cell games are
back compact yeah on xbox yeah go do
that now go rock
then we got gerald mack five dollars
chad the guy who voiced sam fisher and
ghost recon breakpoint he sounds a lot
like michael ironside and young enough
to do any mocap kind of true he does
just go with him
i never i didn't play that so i got this
i like him and we got kids moved home
remember for 19 months shout out to you
sir
they do not need multiplayer to monetize
splinter cells since it's open world you
see it's that it's that it's that middle
ground where i think they're trying to
hit since it's open world they can
charge for time savers make the game
longer and add rpg elements
no
first of all it ain't going to be what
you think so
remember it's going to ship in two
packages
we said two packages
oh okay let me roll back a little bit we
got a couple more
give me a moment please okay i know
where we at
so we have flame two dollar super chat
and the remake will feature samantha
fisher
they're not gonna uncharted that game
man yeah you never know you never know
that we have pillsbury ten dollars with
the chat
great show plus tell rick ross of gaming
that with the louis vuitton hoodie he is
the hype man of the podcast he knows
this already
yeah i need to tell you
you
happy holidays lords love you guys
likewise my brother you know happy
holidays to you hey pillsbury if i touch
your stomach you go oh
[Laughter]
should xbox work to make splendid so
exclusive or day and date game pass yes
they should damn it no splinter cell is
definitely associated with that
good for xbox to lock it up no yeah i i
actually
i feel like
it's not good enough like that game
they need to make sure that's an
exclusive no
put it everywhere who cares um put all
that money into perfect dog because i
don't care about sam fisher doing
whatever for ubisoft i want perfect dark
to be
way better i listen
in all honesty yeah
but this is the thing the perfect thing
is it stuck to first person they didn't
twitch it's a third person so as a
sneaking game okay whatever i don't i
don't use don't allocate funds
from your studios to do what sony did
that's a sony move
all right we're going to lock it down
for six months and i don't care
no well then if we come out on game pass
good if we have a if we have an opening
in our schedule that we can fit you in
it's going to be a point where all these
studios is hitting on all the way are
you saying that third party exclusives
don't matter anymore the gamepad
when all those studios start hitting
you're going to see when dudes start
beating the doors down to get their
games in okay and that's hey if sam can
fit in in the schedule
this game that lost your xbox
if microsoft can make that an exclusive
if they need to make that into i don't
want them to bust a hammy uh trying to
get them in there
how many people are playing it king by
the time that game comes out you're
gonna have a 100 million game pass
subscribers in your mind anyway
there's gonna be a lot of people play
that you know what the last time you
clowned me it was the million people
don't see it see
that wasn't me
this dude says xbox has been losing all
the exclusives to ps lately like alan
wake core tour et cetera
yeah like
look man if you don't go after it
quantum break
nothing loose
but but they got pretty much exclusive
marketing on control but my point is if
you don't go after it
sony might and then let them go ahead
they don't sell studios and no games let
them know what they can get just to
clarify you don't think you'd be an
issue if sony went after that maybe
that's a splitter cell yeah and it's
exclusive that's not a problem listen
listen do it that's a problem like like
if you if if you can do it do it and you
know what i'm gonna say microsoft
podcast listen get clear
do it give me a reason to play the
console do it right i don't i don't want
them so we don't need reasons to play
xbox we need reasons to play places
listen just to confirm well you wouldn't
play it anyway because i mean or quarter
is time right listen
to wait for it my joint got dust on it
um
this is what i'm saying
don't go out of your way
you understand what i'm saying like
well overpaid if
yes you know a lot of times before these
dudes will put millions and millions of
dollars just to to to gate it away from
the other dudes if that's your sole
intention to get it away from gamers all
across
but microsoft does that too they spent
seven point five billion dollars to keep
elder scrolls off of playstation did
they they spent you think however for
elder scrolls they did not bolster their
studios
let's have a real conversation here so
so but but let's act like them reaching
out to square enix yo where's that final
fantasy they did that to bolster their
content yeah like all right let's not
okay
xbox could say
yes we want it everywhere one game pass
everywhere what's the reality of game
game pass it's on everywhere but
playstation right what's the reality of
happening fine
is
that
but but you're gonna you're not gonna
act like phil didn't know that like you
know say like they know full well that
that game passes not seen the light of
day on playstation they know right like
you can't say oh it's out there yeah you
know they can if they want it they know
it's not happening maybe i don't know
it is gated off of their car you did
something wrong
i think maybe i've worded it wrong for
you
i would want it there okay
i don't want them to break a leg trying
to get it
okay
what do you mean so you would want it in
game pass but not no no no
no no
right
you know when you go to the dealership
you want that car
but you're not gonna financially put
yourself in ruin trying to get it so
maybe a game passed back day and date
with everyone else but just in game pass
like like the show like something like
that yeah just like this show that first
party playstation game that they had to
pay for that i thoroughly enjoyed for
that one
is i agree with king to a point that
they need to you know focus on their
stuff over you know getting timed
exclusives but at the same time
when that final fantasy 7 remake part
two hit is gonna do numbers it's gonna
have a lot of coverage in the industry
people are going to put that with the
playstation brand and that's what i'm
saying that look you kidding okay
because king got his place
it doesn't matter
you can do focus on your stuff but i do
feel like some things
microsoft some things microsoft got to
come out of the house and say yo where
that at yes
and then when playstation looks around
and say where's the valve
it's not there right
focus in your house but they you acting
like they can't walk and chew gum at the
same time
yeah
they're so broken
how much is put a cell rebate going cost
like
here's the thing if you're a one console
owner this generation you're going to be
disappointed at some point yeah okay and
and uh because
if you're just strictly about game pass
and xbox you know you're going to miss
out on some exclusives that
playstation decides to go after with
these multi-players and they're doing it
and then vice versa you know there's
games like elder scrolls you're not
going to be able to play if you're just
a playstation owner and
it's it's at the end of the day that's
why i always uh press people and say you
you should own both you know if you want
to play
all these games and and be happy as a
gamer you got to own both yeah it just
feels like playstation is being more
aggressive in that regard like when you
oh
right king we always say
microsoft we said for the past couple
years microsoft your your internal
studios are cooking you need something
tell them sony didn't take that in there
she said y'all gonna wait so he's all
right let's go over to scoring to get
this final fantasy the 16
let let's let's get this core tour from
disney let's give our consumer base
something to play why our stuff cooks
microsoft got to be more aggressive in
that type of way too
microsoft put out more false party games
this year than sony yeah oh my god they
they go microsoft's aggressive yeah they
don't have to be see you're sitting here
you're trying to push a false narrative
it's not a sony did not release more
first party games this year they needed
to have those uh um
deals in place they won't next year
either exactly
next year so they won't be the year
after that either these thoughts that
you're having in your head like oh they
need to run they don't need to run
across the street and break their leg
they go get this stuff okay this is
where i do agree with i hear what you're
saying this year but next year it's
about to get real spooky when horizon
god of war gran turismo is out of
world's not coming out next
right now the only major thing that we
know of we'll be honest is starfield
which is at the end of 2022 right and
that could get pushed back right we
don't know in the future
i would assume that that one wait wait
wait wait did you just say gt gt7 but
you didn't mention ford some motorsport
but
it's not been a first look it's coming
in
they
we have a solid release day in gran
turismo we don't have one for grand you
see what it looks like it can be as
solid as it want to be
and i get that but we have to go what we
know we know right now the gran turismo
is coming out next year we don't know
that about forza we have promises we
don't care did you just see food
like who don't literally they playing
ketchup like they really playing
catch-up you won't stop acting like they
out here busting moves you know what's
funny
like we talking we're talking about the
stuff that they that is coming out next
year
we're not even oh so nice this will be
11. are you ever
we're not even talking about the
announcements they make next year right
we don't know if they come out there and
they say yo
final fantasy 7 remake 2 coming out
2023. we don't and that's going to
generate more hype like like we can't
just go on this mindset with microsoft
don't need to do anything they need to
do just like i get it like microsoft is
doing better than they were but when you
was coming off a two and now you're on a
seven doesn't mean when playstation was
a non-no generational mode no nobody's
saying they don't need to addict what
we're saying is they're they don't need
to be as aggressive going after those
multiplats as uh and you know they will
they'll put them in game pass they'll
get some uh deals going there but at the
same time i think playstation is going
to be way more aggressive this
generation right with going after those
multi-players
for long periods of time
but here's the thing and i agree with
what both of you are saying the key to
me also is that they still have to feed
game pass you still got to feed it at
the end of the day if you're trying to
grow it you can't be so casual where you
not when you got those gaps of course
when sony's putting out a first party
banger and you don't have your banger
lined up it behooves you to do it
outriders in an mlb third-party
situation to bolster the service you
want people in if you play too cool for
school like oh we're going to wait these
guys could generate interest and the
thing that sony's playing dirty is
they're playing dirty with timed
exclusives like they're literally going
and taking pieces off the board they're
not taking them taking them all
significant pieces off the board for
long periods of time when you think
about yours two years is a long time
that's a long time and xbox is not
making that they act
at the top the top of twitch
they i need to see what microsoft's
going to do
i'm sorry first for spoken that's a
playstation exclusive i don't care what
they say time to exclusive by two years
the game's irrelevant yeah let's be real
two years
in the chat he said forza stream uh from
turn ten last week said forza motorsport
is 20 22 he agrees and that's cool he
wasn't saying that it's not coming out
next year we were saying that we have an
actual release date for grant trisball
right and we know because of the
pandemic stuff's getting delayed all the
time oh in the chat so i see an actual
net dates the chat wants you to put some
respect on red fall as well though yeah
we are definitely definitely all right
we got one we went left we went up we
gotta move on look big documentary
addict this is your topic power on six
part series i believe
history of xbox alex set it off man
what'd you feel about this thing so
pretty much it was six videos that came
out and they pretty much went over the
history of the foundation how it was
built uh the people who struggled to get
it into the hands of microsoft
and it was a really it was a really well
done documentary and i really enjoyed it
what i really want to like really really
focus is on the last one we'll just talk
about the xbox one generation and you
know
it's one thing to make a mistake it's
another thing to acknowledge you made a
mistake
and microsoft came out there and man
people say we be
like people say
that a lot of people are too positive
too negative microsoft didn't hold no
blows they're like i there's the time so
they're like we let the consumers down
like like and to come out there and be
so open with your mistakes i gotta i
gotta respect them for that yeah and
that's what i wanna talk about we can
briefly talk about all of them but i
really wanna like how open they were
about all the mistakes from the 360 to
the xbox one like and one thing
i remember how dominant the 360 was i
didn't quite remember how they said it
in that like how crazy they were doing
even what the people people forget how
well the 360 did
this is deering the the the the red ring
of death yeah like this is during all
this like and people like to oh you know
they padded the numbers yeah the numbers
were padded a little bit but
we all know gamers when a plot when a
hardware malfunctions we know
right now people won't go out and buy
that you know it's hot when you gotta go
walmart real quick
let me get let me start off with a pd on
this first i want to get his perspective
did you get a chance for pity to watch
any of the documents uh yeah actually um
myself on my whole stream i actually put
it on we all listened to it uh on friday
so we all listened to it and the thing
there was a couple of really cool parts
there's three parts
that um i just want to touch on really
really quick
um the first part was
when they said that they
first introduced
the
their quote-unquote prototype
of the xbox
and he said that
he said that like
people like didn't really
they were like this is a song this is
like um a demonstration you're not
supposed to have hardware oh yeah and
they were just like i don't care i
brought hardware the directxt versus the
microsoft ce team yes yes he was like
what do you want me to do i brought a
demo what are you gonna want it's a demo
it's a demonstration what are you gonna
do and then the other guys brought
powerpoint presentations yeah that was
cool
i thought that i was just like i was
like
like that's doing them dirty shout out
to you on top of that you know pushing
themselves above everybody else
so that was one thing the other thing
was is that when they were talking about
um the xbox or the red ring of death
them acknowledging the fact they were
like we knew it was broken we just
didn't know we didn't know what was it
what it was doing it was like we were
just going
oh okay what are we gonna do what are we
gonna fix all right we're just gonna
stop production
yeah i was like and you
you know petty pd like
it is it is crazy that they came out
openly on tv
and said yo we were selling broken
content we tried to fix it we
fix one send it out and we were just
like
okay let's hope it works
it was kind of like really really scary
and like i was one of those guys that
ended up
getting the red ring yeah sending it
back i'm sorry and then ended up going i
still need to be able to play yeah and
then bought myself another one
and i was i was one of those guys and
then when i got my other one back i
returned it yeah so like i was just like
like
what do you want me to do i want to play
my games
that's what let you know how
that's how dominant your sister was
because we were still dealing with what
most people i mean they did have to lose
some people but i know what you mean
though i know oh yeah yeah
100
and the other part was
seeing
what they're doing now
and how they took like the their
um
their problems with the xbox one and
saying all right how are we gonna fix
this we need to get ready for it what
are we gonna do with the series x
like
the thought process behind that because
they felt like they
lost the last series
yeah like the last um generation of
consoles
and wanting them to perform better
and seeing how that whole thought
process and mindset behind them was yeah
that was what i thought was really
really interesting that they kind of
just got together and was sitting at the
table going what do we need to do let's
fix this what do you want to do and i
thought that was really awesome yeah and
you know petey what's crazy is just like
like i think it was grainy green he
literally came on that was like that was
the dark area yeah
yeah like the fact that like because a
lot of the stuff in that you know they
were like pr you got to leave the room
for this part yeah like i was wasn't
sure and then there were certain people
that came outside that i wasn't sure was
going to come outside
[Music]
and some of the times that they were
saying when they were having
conversations with executives and stuff
and they're like
cursing and yelling at each other and
i'm like
that would not go that would not go well
now yeah that was crazy let's get uh
lady lyric uh did you get a chance to
watch any of the power on documentary
and if so um what was just some of your
thoughts or some standout points for me
so two points that stood out to me is
one like everybody said like being able
to own the fact that you've made
mistakes in this journey of trying to
build up the xbox it takes a lot yes and
the second thing is especially in the
beginning of the documentary i love that
it showed how business works like a lot
of times is you banging on that
executive's door to get stuff done talk
about the connects girl where when they
were like yo you got to know somebody in
the room
to even be heard to get to bill and the
line was going around the corner and
they was like it would take them a while
just to even be heard about the concept
of making an xbox console continue to do
yeah that and when they brought out the
quota prototype which was just a cpu in
a box
and i was like that's how you have to do
it it's like kamikaze bring it throw
everything at when they're like oh well
we didn't know we could bring hardware
it's like well that's what you're
supposed to do you're supposed to have
something ready to show executives
he's like they didn't know that either
they were playing dirty they was playing
dirty i respected any other standouts
for you lady lyric
um with the red ring of death like it is
interesting to me that like that 360 was
such a standout console like i remember
in 2005 when
it came out you had to have one and
everybody had to have one especially for
me when they announced dead or alive
four as a 360 exclusive i was like you
have to have one
she was like i'm over here that's where
i'm gonna be at
[Laughter]
no doubt absolute salute lord bonds man
yes this documentary a lot of feels like
this is our errors man
yeah uh you know it was one of those
that i watched i watched a lot of
documentaries and i think this
documentary could have been on netflix
or something like this it was so good
and i think a lot of people would enjoy
this even outside of gaming yes because
it the one thing that it did show that
everybody has touched on here is that
transparency a lot of times companies
they won't divulge all the ins and outs
of what went on and like especially the
bad anyway yeah but here they did that
and it was just it was really cool to
see even though we kind of knew some of
this stuff we're like you know we lived
some of this stuff the red ring of death
was huge i went through five xboxes
myself and my fifth one i said f u x box
i'm done and i walked away and i didn't
i didn't buy another one
uh because it it really upset me so bad
that i had five that that it happened to
i know and i'm telling you it would
happen within days or weeks and
it would just red ring wow and by the
fifth one i took that one did the towel
trick made it come back to life took it
to gamestop sold it and got a ps3 you
make sure i work in front of things
yeah exactly um but i was just done with
it um but what i liked about the
documentary though really was that
transparency and at the beginning
i liked how they talked about the window
the the uh
the directx team was going against the
window ce team and at the time they were
talking about how windows the windows ce
team talk about built like the ethernet
port and everything for the dreamcast
just and i remember all that i remember
looking at the windows ce logo on the
back of the dreamcast
and you know just
knowing and then when they touched on
the fact that they saw the wii and they
wanted something like that so they went
with a connect and video let me let me
see the transparency there is so so
crazy i want to stop you at one point
you said it in reference to me and king
talked about it offline but
when you talk about the windows ce team
versus the directx team that actually
won right
the directx team that was really an
uphill battle because at the end of the
day the ce team had the more experience
if you really look at it they had
they were on the 3do right
they did what you call it they did the
um the dreamcast they had the os they
were the more experienced console making
kind of people whereas the directx guys
were kind of this rag tag misfits and
let's be honest the stuff they were
asking for was so ahead of the game as
far as like yo it ha we're not bending
on ethernet in the box we're not bending
on the hard drive i thought that was
very interesting for them to to have
that mindset and then like everyone
everybody
mentioned the the whole bringing the
prototype was kind of like the killing
blow to lane what was kind of
interesting about that whole dynamic is
that they
at that time as well too is they focus
on how bill gates was how steve bomber
was and
you got to see so
you got to hear about things that you
wouldn't guess like with some of these
uh execs you know and with with steve
baumer one thing that i really liked was
the part where uh they were having all
these problems with the red ring
and uh yeah peter had to come in and and
face uh steve baumer and he was ready to
get a you know time lashing and just
like just
you know uh get sent out that office he
was ready for it yeah and steve ballmer
just said take care of it you know he
said it was going to cost a billion
something dollars and he said just take
care of it yeah absolutely and uh that
was
that was so awesome to see because or
here because
you would think that these uh
companies uh would any other company it
seem would fold yes and something like
that you have a billion dollar problem
here
and you don't even know what the problem
is at the time yeah you're just look
you're scrambling for something
and here it is the guy's just ready to
write that check and say fix it they
believe in xbox that much to go forward
with it and all these mistakes the
culmination of everything you would
think that
the company would fold you think this
console shouldn't be here let's be
honest right yeah
should not be here right now all of the
consoles shouldn't be here i agree
they've went through so much except for
this last one yeah they went through so
much it's funny you said that fox like
other than microsoft who would have been
able to survive all those things that
you mentioned and what's interesting is
all those people that are there that are
still there yeah
they they've been there for the ride and
and all those ups and downs and
that is what makes this document
documentary so fantastic and in the end
yeah it is a bit emotional it is because
you
you you feel for these people and what
they've gone through
it's it's really awesome i just i just
want to say those people that have been
there the whole entire time
those are like those die hard people
that are like
they are there for it and they love
their job and at the same time you could
tell that they've gotten the crap kicked
out of them but at the same time they
love it so much
yeah
i'm good i i forgot like i i'll tell
like i have adhd like
if
it's on top of my mind and then it's
gone
write it down
but i feel you father i definitely hear
you going away but uh let's get
something
feels man
watching that um
just i mean again
i'll go back to the beginning for a
second but
the moment i saw lord ha
in yo when we see online for the oh
some type of um
like um
how kind of uh um
affirmation like it it just it just felt
to us
and if you notice i you know
he was he was the fan that they left the
camera on for the longest that i noticed
like how crazy does we see one of all it
was one of our homies and then shout out
to lord hawkers hob how is the king of
i'm gonna stand on this line no matter
what oh yeah yep ha is i'm not
pre-ordering i'm gonna go and i'm gonna
be there i'm gonna be part of this and
if it takes 24 hours and if i'm not
mistaken i think ha got his for free
because he was there the entire time
yeah so um
just to see that and all of us it's the
funny thing is all of us were there but
we weren't standing online because we
had ours pre-ordered and we were picking
up the next day we were just there for
the festivities of it yeah the launch
but and we didn't get we didn't go to
toys r us me and you were at electronic
boutique right and then cog was across
the street i think at eb at another eb
and so again we were just there for the
festivities not to stand online and
those were fun times
you don't see that anymore you don't see
anything of that magnitude anymore when
they took over they literally took over
times square um
to sell this to you and it was such it's
just a beautiful time those memories are
so vivid to me to see one of our own
kind of spotlighted that way and
especially him because him he is the
epitome of i'm gonna sit it rain shine
snow i'm gonna be here and i'm going to
get this so um that was great to see but
going back to the beginning
to me
just to cool just to see the evolution
of this console that was never supposed
to be there right if sega doesn't have
infighting and collapse there's no
reason for microsoft to even think about
getting into space they were killing the
world with windows they didn't need to
even think about it and
shout out to sheamus and the directx
team for what for convincing bill gates
falsely in the moment
convincing bill gates that they were
going to put by telling them hey we're
going to put windows in in the living
room
and that was not true yeah
well i don't i don't necessarily think
it wasn't true i think at that time he
thought he was going to but when they
actually got around doing it they're
like oh wait a minute this ain't gonna
work who's telling bills
while you're on that point uh i love the
part where uh he showed bill the boot up
and he was like how did it boot up so
fast like he's just stunned
because none of his computers can boot
up that fast yes
because we took everything out yeah
you know what's crazy how well
the xbox 360 did and how much they were
willing to like oh here's a billion fix
this do the ups thing yeah but like it
shows how bad that xbox one destroyed
the morale in the entire brand
because it's like they go from investing
a billion dollars to a couple years
later they're having a hard time getting
funding for games
to see don matrick come out and speak
and
he he was still very sort of
you know
defensive he looked defensive
but a little like an executive yeah for
coming out and talking about him for
coming outside though right and
we have a super chat that alludes to the
fact that some people say i some people
say we right he was definitely a wee guy
um
and
his you know his take that yeah maybe
that wasn't the right way to go about it
a right way to talk about it even though
he honestly never brought up the you
have a 360 for you
they ain't doing that dirty he's like he
showed up don't play that
yeah
but all right one point though i want to
get before i get back to you so
i got to give him credit on one thing
and
we we clowned him and rightfully so for
the xbox one error right the tv focus
was just over the top it was just
ridiculous they were back making tv
studios you know i remember all the evil
memories started to come back and i'm
like oh no right
but remember he did take over towards
the end of the 360 era he did and to his
credit i had to give him this one
netflix the netflix the the let's be
real
they are really responsible for having
these streaming services media and
entertainment
part of the box and a lot of these
people they started to mention how sony
and them was like yo they getting that
bag for having all these apps
on your joint so i give them credit for
that and yes they did try to catch the
connect wave i mean um
the we wave with the connect which they
did do fine but the problem is they went
so over the top with xbox one and it was
so much they forgot they lost sight of
who they was at that point
is
he pushed he pushed things that were so
far
advanced yes at the time
but but it wasn't even gaming related it
was more tv it was more you know
videos and movies and things like that
he didn't know how to message it like if
you think about with the state of xbox
today
all of that stuff came to fruition and
it's just it's a matter of
the industry being ready for it the fan
being ready for it and how you message
it if you message it like hey we're
telling you what you need
it's never going to go over well right
great ladies and gentlemen real
quick uh one of the things that was
it was hilarious to me is when they
showed up to the games conference with
the like big giant
xbox fell apart and it wouldn't work
and they were
the the actual xbox itself didn't turn
on when they when they showed the actual
thing yeah that didn't turn off gdc
right the x itself the x itself was the
one that they they had the one they had
they were soldering like yeah exactly
and then they had the backup underneath
the stage in case so that the gameplay
would be parallel
um
i i think this to fonz's point the one
of the biggest things i took away from
this entire story is the transparency of
when we messed up when you talk about
the fact that hey
we might things might look completely
different in the gaming landscape if
they had taken the bet on grand theft
auto 3.
that was a big one that's a big one um
the fact that they owned they they owned
what happened with the with the xbox 360
and and how it absolutely could have run
them completely into the ground how they
owned what happened with xbox one and
kind of that showing you the steps that
they took to turn the ship around you
know when phil came on and it was just
like to me the transparent it was
absolutely everything that we've been
talking about xbox
in this new era 2017 forward whatever um
it all came through in this documentary
right and uh
the fact that they can speak candidly
about the things that we
we've seen like since we've been
podcasting we've seen this slide
and for them not to sugarcoat that stuff
and to come out and address it and to
see where they are now because to me
this showing that right showing that and
being so candid about it makes the
victory lap is happening right now yes
exactly much sweeter it really does let
me get so yeah
i love dip man
you know one thing i i don't think we've
talked about a lot is
how open they were about talking about
sony
yeah they were saying that they were
sitting there around the the laptop and
when they announced the price they all
started celebrating
people forget that 360. that was a big
moment i agree one year they turned
around and did it right back to us
[Music]
you brought a playstation 4 because it
was cheaper you use 100 less and you
went to that they lost the power there
and all right let's get it let's get it
there's a couple of things that stands
out to me first of all i want to salute
each and every last person at microsoft
that made
everything possible yes because to be
honest with you every console shouldn't
exist except for the last one
all right every console
six months to to to from from concept to
store shelf that's incredible yeah
to ship before the playstation 2. and my
timeline was off in my head i have
revision accessory i thought that the
360 i mean the um xbox one went up
against the playstation one yeah we had
it
yep
and it didn't you know um the og xbox it
didn't yeah so
um just watching
these people
go to work every day and who is true
soldiers i i say it to this day
if i'm going to war i'm taking steve
ballmer with me
the most energetic passionate dude he
was it was a reason why he was bill's
right-hand man yeah he was just
successful you know um we deify these
individuals
and
people can say that we don't yes
we do i got you all right because it
took this rock star of a person that was
in a different realm
to
realize
and i got to give credit to sony for
this
you birthed xbox
i by your arrogance and your dominance
you birth xbox
by
the decimation of sega because you went
all out to destroy nintendo sega was a
byproduct of that destruction
but at the same time
you put a visual
to bill gates head
that saw no pc in the house right and
basically that was one of the directx
team's selling points to get bill to get
him to invest because they were like if
you don't best want to play in this
console space are you comfortable giving
sony the living room are you comfortable
letting them go at it because they know
you've been waiting what's funny because
i have to leave here in one second but
what's funny i like is
how
like when they were talking about that
last one where they were the os wasn't
going to be in it like a very fractured
version of it he said bill went ham on
all like ham on all
and what i liked is
they
they're one thing that they always hit
him with they were like
bill we know you upset
we know you wanted this os
but he's like what are you more upset
with the fact that
we were going to put a smaller os in the
in the xbox yeah or the fact that
playstation about to take your doritos
it was real good okay
and
well i gotta go you guys i i i
appreciate everyone coming through
yeah yeah yeah
but i appreciate her coming through uh
and uh it's been a good day man i'll
talk to you guys oh all right
i'll talk to you next year all right
i'll see you next year all right
so
watching all all the heads and everybody
come through everybody has their own
style and how
they were uh using leadership
you know um money was readily available
for um
for your guy
uh that you just
yeah that you love so much um
i wanted you to say it
about that but but you know um
you know you have ravi bach
that
was working in that space and that kind
of broke him yes i understand that gave
his reservation
yeah
and and these people was literally
writing a resignation
as they were working and they had it on
a desk and
the fear of bill gates and how i'm going
to deliver this to him i'm not going to
believe this i'm not going to bring this
to him but i love the fact that bill put
them in a in a pit to fight
bad guys
yes but he was but he was testing the
medal of men
men and women
he was testing the metal and the loyalty
to this company because if you cannot
stick this through get out the door
and my opinion i was so wrong in my
opinion of where xbox fit in microsoft's
company and a lot of people are wrong
dead wrong because it is a priority i
always said that they were sitting at
the little table they never were
they were always at the big table
because this has always been
the leading into their end games yes
side projects as phones side projects is
these other stuff that they were trying
that weren't successful this is hugely
successful especially when steve obama
can sit back and say right to check
because peter moore thought it was going
to be a fight going into this office and
it wasn't a fight going into this office
i do got to cut one point though because
you're right from 360 on
right but oh gee the vibe i got yeah
correct me if i'm wrong
is that
they knew
bill was gonna hand it over to bomber
right right
the vibe i got
was like barman was like why are we
messing with this when officers oh no no
we do yeah
no no no no
obama's a money man a numbers dude right
yeah right and the numbers weren't
acting right to the wallet to the bottom
line right but also it's taking the dude
out of his comfort zone but when you
convince him yeah he's behind him
and once he was interacting i agree all
right so i'm i'm i'm i'm jumping from
heads pause to
to to now we have the don
and his arrogance he's still in his
arrogance
because he's been proven right
yes yes yes
because he he's been proven right he's
he wasn't wrong he wasn't
he didn't speak eloquently enough to get
his message across but
he killed blockbuster
yeah
he can literally say i'm the one to kill
blockbuster because at up until that
time blockbuster and and you know
and people your older your parents and
your aunties your cousins y'all were
going with the proven brand this netflix
red thing yeah
i don't know about this right right you
know and sometimes you order a disc and
it don't show up and you know it's like
i'm not gonna mess with i'm just gonna
go down to the store and i'm gonna get
it from from the people that i mess with
right
once it was on your xbox and that
initial that was huge
it was huge it killed blockbuster so he
killed blockbuster he understands where
he's going with it he made the deal for
for football yeah remember that football
deal allowed me to watch football on
four different channels while i'm
watching my game
so
a lot of things that he brought to it he
brought things to the xbox to connect he
saw
they were looking at nintendo and the
influence that nintendo brought to the
market the connect was a direct result
of the wii right the wii was a huge boom
they sold
100 million uh copies of this thing
we got to do the same thing even though
the connect was the most successful
peripheral for a console in the home
space that gave him the incentive
attempt to forward and if you can if you
think about it he's not wasn't wrong
wrong for even putting it
in the box with xbox one because
developers
need to have the base to have it the
problem was the mandatory
like the fact that 100 was the 100
and the fact that you didn't give people
an option to say at the jump which is
what phil did
you have the base version without it if
you don't want any part of that like
they were selling it like yo you had to
have it it won't work without it
remember all that yeah yeah but
this is what you can tell i know where
you're going i know where you're going
right so i got to respect them for
sitting there and he takes the
excoriation of it while phil reaps the
benefits it's like going out presidents
you know they signed their bills into
law but
that president that just came in
those benefits i disagree
i disagree only because you're right in
the aspect that he was right on one part
of the business strategy where you know
he wanted the tv and all that stuff
right but it was the messaging that he
himself carried across that was awful
and that's where he was wrong and and
and that's why he was a bad president
let's say oh yes yes and and so when
you're not when you're the head of a
gaming uh you know
company and you're trying to push out
games and stuff and all you're talking
about is tv and netflix and stuff like
that
they don't want to hear that gamers
don't want to hear that and we didn't
want to hear that i remember at the time
i said i'm not buying an xbox one
because of don
the infamous i mean the influence i have
a council for you that was like that was
that was that was that was like that was
like but
somebody who should have the private
right in the proper just media training
but that doesn't come out of your mouth
tony did the same exact thing
sony said you're going to work a double
job to be had to have the privilege
right
we saw what happened and we saw what
happened but he didn't watch history
because in his arrogance yeah
he shot for the sky on the big bag and
one of them to be bigger than ever and i
oh
yeah
but he just lost sight he got his eye
off the ball
on on on what was actually important he
didn't know how to read the room right
all right so let me get down to phil
dominic's mexicans
the golden child
because when they're people and yo petey
i mean if you really watch the
documentary listen to how everybody
talks about them
[Music]
listen to how
everyone talks about maybe because he's
the current one there
right
but understand
they already knew he could yeah
when he got in
they knew he could
they just wanted to see it happen and
when it's happening he's like yeah he
he's the one because remember he's been
rocking since the beginning he's there
he comes up from inside the company so
he plays games so he goes in there with
a mindset of a gamer
so all this is a byproduct of his actual
involvement
they told you don don't play games
right so when when robbie bach tells you
he don't play games and don doesn't play
games
when i say jim doesn't play games
you got to see what i'm talking about
right
the benefit for the consumer will always
be on that player that has love for you
he has love feet
the easiest thing is
they were at their weakest
put him in front
and now they're at their strongest he
told you they would never lose the power
narrative ever again went out and got
all these studios back to back to back
to back to back to back because he
understood the deficit and he listened
to you guys talk if you don't think he's
watching and listening and that's what a
gamer would do he's not in the boardroom
looking at numbers at the white sheet
the white sheet ain't gonna tell him how
you feel yeah so
when i saw that whole thing in his
entirety i'm like man i have a different
respect for each and every last member
that helped
bring stuff to because people lost
families relationships all types of
stuff and and mentally just said i'm
never going into gaming space again in
fact did you see when phil had to talk
about how like
it was the morale and the damage that
the don and that ever did
yeah was so bad that people were coming
up to phil crying
yeah and like they didn't want to be
here and that that like their their
opinions are not respected and said i
got you it's it was crazy i got to get
it i got to fill this drawer i'll jump
in if you finished i did it i'm i'm done
look it was this is amazing we're fine
this was absolute this is a level of
journalism and doc a documentary
documentary you rarely i like when they
was going to buy nintendo yeah that was
funny
absolutely
that they was right
they went out
[Music]
salute to the directx team from the very
beginning their tenacity to never give
up with that vision we wouldn't get xbox
that's just what i want same assault
yeah
yeah i definitely would love to have
that be honored shameless yeah that
entire team man what i also love about
the is that they spotlighted a lot of
the team that we don't that we forget
about we forget about it yeah like kevin
backes one of the smartest dudes on the
team
shout out to ed
fry's yeah you know what i'm saying but
yeah salute to him because
he really solidified i didn't realize
asian empires went back that long like
yeah
wow this is crazy and like that was a
big game and then they believed in the
pc scene with gaming and then that
translator and then free he had people
in the room to help them navigate
because it's like you had to know
somebody to get an audience with the
great bill like it was some real
dominant spartacus situation like you
know you get an audience
you know what i didn't realize was like
a real like a another like sort of
golden child within the organization was
jay allard right
jay allen to do with the you know with
the hoodie and and and then
jackie
dude like when they showed the letter
that initial letter that he wrote to fit
uh to bill about like the internet and
getting getting in on the internet and
it was like dude you need to do this
like and he was like you know whatever
20 year old kid
he's daring to tell bill gates what he
has to do that was crazy yeah that was
crazy so that that right there the other
thing i wanted to touch on last thing
is bungie
in the um in the og era because oh yeah
shout out to staton was part of this
which i didn't really see the young
state in there
but the thing i didn't realize was like
halo was looking really spooky before it
got me like this
you don't remember i don't even remember
that you don't remember we saw we saw
halo on the mac and we were like it was
it was third person and they had like
strategy elements and we're like all
right i don't know what this like
it was running like 10 frames a second
but when they had it it was running at
that 510 and it was like a couple of
months left before launch for that to
come together the way it came together
and then again now moving forward with
him
with halo 2 on the 360. how
you know what i've noticed another thing
halo is always under the pressure
of microsoft to do they showed me yo
they've been dealing with this this this
infinite this ain't nothing yeah they
say halo's got so much pressure on it
every single generation and to see them
go through that way and stay in where in
the room the way he went in the room
with infinite now and was like we need
more than yeah you know what i'm saying
and that gives you coming out one year
satan is that dude i got so much respect
for him he's the closer man he's the
closer he gets it over the line and
makes it right so salute to that so that
was that that og era was lit shout out
to peter mortal coming through when sega
was about to fall out yeah i was
speaking to them was like look let me
tell you i was gonna slide all that
stuff over there yeah but he's like
she's like none of the retailer's gonna
mess with y'all you can look like he was
giving up this straight business but we
are dependent on you to survive this
year yes yes and these this whole you
know documentary was basically one of
the best showcases of a rise fall in the
horizon
it it really was it was amazing
they got me emotional because oh me too
my brother gamer you remember every
single moment of this we were there day
one
everything yeah everything and you're
like yo i remember that yo that was yeah
and this was a low point and this is a
great point and the thing is when you
when you think about the xbox one right
and and the the horrible initial real tv
tv tv right but the thing is a couple of
weeks later
it was on a platter for them to to
regain the game narrative right when
they showed rise and everybody was
receptive to it until the price yes and
then that was it because yes everybody
once they saw the games they were like
okay
they all right the tv thing is there but
they still mean business on the game
front they shot dead right i agree
and then all of a sudden the price right
i was like
you're right
cuz i remember when they did tv tv i
didn't flip i remember what i was doing
i was like yo this is their personal
showcase they say e3 when e3 come
they're going to show the games right
they show the game but to saw's point
the price and you said you you mandatory
bundling this connect and then you don't
know what the digital future is and then
we all know what sony did with the trade
uh
speaking to halo and how it's been such
a big part of xbox another big thing
that they did with halo was with
machinima with rooster teeth when they
did red versus blue yes yeah
huge so yeah like again you know that
then you get 360 to peter moore joint i
love the aggressiveness i go front when
the mad world came on king
i heard it yeah
they were right nothing at that time
looked like that looked like that
nothing can't get that on the
playstation
yeah it was in the game there's just the
advertisement alone there's nothing like
that it's gonna happen all over again
with that grit
that tone that mood it had that
commercial every time it came on i
remember going to the television no
matter what i was doing i went to that
television and i watched that you know
what it was like i can't believe i'm
you didn't have that you know i'm saying
that
just to hear the transparency because
you know they'd be saying they still
don't have that
it is
but you know at the end of the day like
that obviously the xbox one aired all
the painful memories of of that you know
what i'm saying and but i i got to give
kingness like
i got a motion where phil came out i was
like yo like
he was really
given
the bad hand like the hand was it was so
low the morale was so low it was so bad
they literally lost their way you get
rid of speaking that he had no quick
thing
did you see that aaron greenberg like i
felt bad for him at one point when he
was talking about those dark days
he's like
bro like even what you know it's bad
when major nelson got bad stuff to say
basically no devastation
they also got bad stuff yeah what the
hell we were doing
like what was going on the game passed
game past game pass games
with the playing they had the white ball
it was like okay one price get rid of
that connect two yeah we're gonna do the
idea at xbox get charla get back on in
the game because remember playstation
was kicking off with the indy with the
joint
then we had game pass birth the birth of
game plan they have missed you phone
like okay okay and then as it goes on
you see the back come through
the back of pat and then you go okay
then they do the bethesda moment and
they literally it was like a redemption
it's like
well done yeah well it was to to your
point about about phil yeah it was that
i think phil
just just with his positivity and his
kind of demeanor yeah i think he just he
he made people feel like it's going to
be okay yes
he did it it's just that thing where you
look at him he's like he's a calm dude
he's not the dude that's going to come
out yelling and screaming he's just
going to he sees the job in front of him
and he's gonna do his best to fix it and
i think that's what they needed at that
time where it's like
just be calm stay the course yes we're
working on everything and when you see
the progression because it's one of
those things one of the things where
some people some some you know some
execs are really good at amping you up
and we're going to do this and the other
at the end of the day the process is
super slow or a lot of stuff doesn't
happen right
bill is the
the calming kind of force where he's
like
it's gonna take a long time but this
this this this and this and i guarantee
you it's gonna be better and it's just
like to see it yeah and to see his to
see how they like to king's point how
they spoke about him yeah it was just
like
this sort of calming sort of presence
there yeah
it was it was just everybody
when he got the position yeah
he was one there from from the beginning
i'm just saying
anytime i had interaction with him
he asked me how the show go yeah and i
told wifey the other day um he had asked
me about the show that i didn't like
yeah and he was like how do you feel
about the show mm-hmm i said uh okay i
have your moment i'm not gonna talk
about it now
and he just you just look like i'm i'm
i'm not
the hard work that you put in
it ain't for me to talk about what i
thought was wrong now because i'm not in
your shoes and i don't know the deals of
all the information right you know
that's why i said you can't make uh you
know uh decisions based or assumptions
based on what you
think happened or what went on i
understand that it's business and
there's a lot of things that he had to
do but
to say this point
the reassurance thing yes and i've seen
it firsthand with you
you said very pointly
how come i don't have a baseball game
yeah i did say that to phil
how come i don't have a baseball game
and you know we had this game we had
this guy he was ringing him off he said
well
we're working on it and you know
licensees is very tough
that same licensee cover
get a sad game pass and all i could do
is smile because he wasn't flustered he
answered your question to the best of
his ability but then oh boy deliver it
oh no for sure
in a funky way
the thing you realize with him is he's
not afraid to have the difficult
conversations that's what you know he's
not yeah it matters a lot it matters a
lot because you gotta you can't
sugarcoat it you can't you know whatever
but no this thing was phenomenal i never
loved it what's crazy is that you
realize the power
the power of messaging and saying the
wrong thing if you think about if you
think about like the moment the moment
don matrix said those words
it was it was over
and it was oh and and the crazy thing is
and the crazy thing is right they
obviously they stepped on the rake
following that right the price point the
connecting the box the the fact that
they didn't really have a lot of great
games throughout the course of the of
the console generation that they were
exclusive they did a lot to kind of
support that that that angst that people
had about them in the beginning right
but the messaging literally broke them
from the very beginning and there was
really no coming back from yeah it's so
it's it's crazy what the power of
messaging is in words really does and
you saw it on both sides because like
king said
i forgot
how bad
sony bungled their messaging which gave
the 360 even more of a rain daylight
right yeah you know what i'm saying
because they came there they were a year
out but then everybody was shook like yo
ps3 go come on what they gonna do and
they said they would huddle up around
that east
to see what's going on then they say 600
and they're like oh they were clapping
like we got the we got the higher price
one we got the 649 one
one
with the full back and back yeah that's
what i had too yeah yeah but the thing
is when he said the privilege to own one
you you will earn the president it was
crazy
[Music]
the the difference between don matrick
and
phil spencer over the years
um
it's obvious why they went with phil
spencer it's like yin and yang man yeah
you've got don was the total opposite
type of guy he focused more on things
that weren't
really
something that the gamer really wanted
to hear and where phil is focusing on
games
and uh the future of xbox with game pass
and
i i think it's incredible to see
this rise yes
at xbox right now
it's really a great time for gaming
right now because they're actually
competing again i think it's gonna be at
an end
and um i just hope
when it is at an end
we don't do the thing that we always do
what
pick wrong
oh yeah
yeah what do you mean his his his ten
years i mean
yeah yeah
i find it interesting i saw a lot of
sarah bond in this side oh oh yeah
listen
i
i look at her there and i see
everything that she's done with game
pass and stuff like that and she is
progressive in these spaces
um
and she plays games yes yeah my thing is
for my ceo
please
play games if this is what you're
supposed to be lording over
don't tell me you don't eat donuts and
you own dunkin donuts yeah i don't know
what it is i think the xbox themselves
don't make i don't think they step on
that rake anymore xbox themselves i
think the problem would come in is if
whoever succeeds satya
doesn't care about that's a complaint oh
yeah
i think xbox them i think xbox has it
figured out it's just going to be a
matter of if they're going to get the
same support from the next scene right
now that to me is phil's
greatest victory that we don't talk
about enough yeah a business and a
numbers guy is great for a company right
but when you're managing a company or
overseeing the entire you know xbox
division yeah you have to be somebody
who plays games in my opinion
even if it was on the playstation's eye
i still say that about jim like jim he's
he's a numbers guy but you can tell he
doesn't play games yeah like the guy's
not a game player yeah
and and you miss something with that
because when you have the understanding
of games as a ceo you're going to know
hey this is i have the
finger on the pulse of gamers here i
know what gamers want i know gamers are
talking about this and this genre game
this is what we need to do and let's get
it done you know what i'm saying like
jim is totally different yeah it doesn't
have that it's an advantage it's
actually an advantage that's why games
are 70 bucks
it is that too that part two
move on like i said um solve actually
make this quick because this last one i
just wanted to say a few things um
before then we can read this which has
after but um did uh the season finale
iop
2021 y'all we ran another another year
so i just want to you know shout out
everybody the team and everything and um
it's been it's been crazy it's been it's
been a fun journey you know um just
seeing us as a group you know kind of
rise and and let's be honest like
during a period of you know this
pandemic
typically you know we're outside like
that our thing is we like to be outside
you know petey's here he knows you know
uh what's great but you will know you
know that what we what we like to do so
you know that was taken from us
obviously and still being able to do
stuff and then you know up and down yeah
personally for all of us right all of us
had something going on i had the surgery
at one point
i laid off at one point you know what
i'm saying so we got that you know we
lost our brother dizzy that was that was
that was crazy addict lost his dad
solved you had personal stuff going on
king you definitely have personal stuff
going on we all have stuff going on but
every week for the most part we show up
you know what i'm saying we show up and
to think about we about to take two
weeks off it's like a big deal for us if
we don't never take them
you know but i mean i'm just proud i'm
proud of what we're doing we hit 10k
this year which was tremendous for us um
i think the future is great i want to
shout out um
a lot of tremendous episodes we've had
you know we've had amazing you know
obviously colin was huge we had colin on
you know what i'm saying jess seth
chazelle was awesome he's awesome jason
ronald always comes to jason jason
schreier jason schreib was big i'm very
proud to have him on as well um
obviously you know paris danny payne
yeah
maddie acg like we had a good year y'all
like we had a really good year
considering everything that was going on
and last thing is obviously you know
lady derek is here and uh petey's here i
want to shout out log deck man because
lognet they're the backbone like they
they give us that that media you know
that that reinforcement that legitimizes
us and the articles it's just been
insane salute to the editorial if
they're not listening um wait hey gotta
know if i've seen you in there but um
flame i see you in there holding it down
um shout out to josh redding
he's just a beast when it comes to just
writing editorial making us look right
gotta shout out homie nick you know
saying nicholas downey
killing it the reviews all that you know
um hi the admin doing his thing
i love our meetings that we all do we
get together we power wow you know what
i'm saying and we we just kind of come
up with ideas and stuff and i'm just
like i said salute to the whole team you
know it's been really
really a fun journey and i'm just going
to open it up to y'all i just wanted to
say that because i was just like
sometimes you got to take a step back
and just look
at what you did you know because we
always being king we always like oh it's
the next thing what's the next thing we
go you know what i said but you gotta
sometimes you gotta look at the moment
and really
be proud of it and i'm excited for 2022.
i love y'all but i want to get those
balls off to everybody in the team like
salute it's a fun year for everybody and
salute to the to the chat and also chat
what i want y'all to do if i can you
don't have to super chat this but let me
know what was some of your favorite like
moments or iop just episodes or whatever
i want to know what's going on with
y'all but i'm opening it up to y'all um
let's start with alex what's going solve
you know what what did you feel you know
as far as the year stuff
yeah i i think you you said everything
that i honestly needed to be said but
it's been a it's been a year um i think
overall i think it's felt better than in
2020 in terms of just you know just us
as as a community as an entire planet
trying to figure out you know how we get
through this pandemic
um and but again this year we also had a
lot of tragedy we had triumph and we had
tragedy we lost some some people near
and dear to us uh
whether it's on the log that team
whether it's you know people that have
been on our show you know shout out to
nintendo guru
our brother sin had had a lot of you
know unfortunate tragedy absolutely and
his and his family this year so um
but through it all the word all the
triumphs you know as we as we come to
the end of the year i think the triumphs
are what stands you know head and
shoulders above everything else and i
think you know the perseverance that
we've seen from everyone in the
community just to keep you know keep
smiles on our faces and just you know
playing these games and talking about
the fun stuff that we love
i think it's brought us to this point
where
you know looking forward to 2022 it
feels like nothing but great things
ahead for everyone um so yeah i just
want to thank obviously my brothers for
having me on here with them and and and
having me be part of this journey
because you know chicago tell you man
growing up i was i was a quiet kid
until a quiet kid you know whatever got
bullied whatever and then
hanging out with cog hanging out with
king that that made me come out of my
shell and now you can't get me to shut
up
[Laughter]
but um
but um
yeah so uh you know for me being part of
this journey and to see you know
my brother shining and seeing addict out
there doing his thing and changing up
his life came to be to see king
on a stage where everybody can see king
he's like oh my god like the fact that
we that everybody that what we know
about this man
and he just he just it it's it's like a
fish to water like
it's just amazing
the things he comes up with and like
yeah
you know it's going to be fire like you
know you're going to get it
get it
then he'll surprise you like the timing
like he'll set you up
and you don't realize that boom you've
been set up and it comes and it's like
bam it's boom exactly and then it'll be
a thoughtful a thoughtful thing on a
topic or a point that you don't expect
him to feel that way about yes um so
that that and that's always been king
and of course you my brother like to see
the stuff that you've been through this
year leading up to this year and to sort
of always have to be that that that
shoulder that people come to you know
when they need help and sometimes us not
realizing that you need it as well um to
see
all the blessings that have fallen upon
you this year it's
and i i still think you deserve more um
honestly dude i'm so happy for you and i
can't wait to see what happens in the
future so i'm just i'm glad to be part
of the ride and to the community like
you guys
again i'm not i'm the dude that's kind
of quiet like when it's somebody's
birthday like i usually don't
i'll go and see a d and be like happy
birthday bro you know whatever i'm not
really the guy that's gonna be put the
big message out there all the time i do
it sometimes but
um and i'm kind of resistant to people
sort of entering that circle when it
comes to me i have you know i think i
can count my close close friends on two
hands and that's that's fine by me but
at the same time
i've learned to sort of see the beauty
in this community and the people that
just want to have
share that love of gaming and just
really really have it be that this pure
thing so to you guys who come in here
week after week and support us and
listen to us and super chat and and just
engage with everything that we do
thank you from the bottom of my heart
because
you guys make it you guys make it like
not at all because for us we could we
could they could lock us in a room and
we could just do this and we'd be fine
with it
because we know we have and we have and
we have right and we were fine with it
but to see that people gravitate to us
and that
the energy that we've had since we've
been little kids
can still resonate 30 years later
it is it is such a beautiful thing to
see like i sometimes my wife my wife
makes me laugh cause she'll say he's
like i've never seen grown men gossip as
much as you guys do
but it's like
when you think about what we're talking
about like it's like
i'm able to sit and talk about this
thing that i've loved since i was five
years old
and it is so it's gratifying and it's
just it's so fulfilling so once again
thank you to everybody who comes to the
realm every single week engages with
lognet because those guys are amazing
too i know what it is to have to sit
there and edit and stuff and you know
and i wish i could be more a part of
that because you guys do an absolutely
amazing job but everything that that has
anything to do with iron lords and log
net in this community it is just so
amazing to see the growth and the love
that people just bring to it so again
thank you so much i can't wait to see
what awaits us in the future okay
and that's exactly how his lord's
minutes go
you can't get me to shut up thank you
beautiful
first first i want to say um
rest in peace to dizzy yeah
like
i
i don't reach out to people much i'm
like a real
as as much as i joke around and stuff
like that i'm a real closed-off
individual when it comes to certain
things and
i really like dizzy yeah so much so i
send him a doctor doom cause he him and
i should love doctors
he always but
that's the real one
nothing he would send me comics to doom
choking out they don't i'm like all
right all right
just
love his enthusiasm for certain things
that i shared as well but
because i have to say this before i
forget before we went from dizzy shout
out to clowns
the toy drive for his son parker we were
able to get something so that parker
could have a good christmas without his
father and i thought that was really
special
to have that happen rose hit me up she
said she got the boxes under the tree oh
oh there's more to come there's no way
to come wait like i said he's gonna live
on
and um
you know i definitely want to shout the
community for coming together for our
brother and the community for coming
together
on our stream for him
yeah we had everybody pull up you know
all walks whether it be regular content
creator or that person just randomly
talked to him or executives you know
came through and remembered him and gave
him his flaws i'm sorry because i had
that
that was the most beautiful thing that i
i wish we never had to do like yeah yeah
yeah yeah
i just
i really love our chat
yes you guys get me in such a way pulse
that is absolutely nuts but you'll do it
in such a respectful manner
you guys i christopher heart can come
here and feel safe
without being disrespected talked down
to
joked with oh i disrespect him
i have no i have no ill will against
christopher he's just wrong most of the
time that's all
like he knows what canada is but um
oh my god i i i love it i i i love all
of this stuff um
god
all right
i'll be lying to you if i told you i
didn't see you in your best light always
like i would be lying to you
like if i
you already knew i told you anyway you
know with certain things how things are
going to go
like i'm blessed with and cursed with
sight so
uh
in in in down moments
i was just gonna give you some
reassurance and understand that
it's gonna be a bright uh light at the
end of this uh situation and definitely
uh shout out to a lot of situations that
made that uh a thing
um and that
that situations know how i feel about it
um
sovereign
you know i tell a little story
of
you gathering a lot of stuff and making
sure i had things
to to
that i was missing out on
yeah yeah and um
i also
tell a lot of stories about
hey uh you know i can't do
that
right now because of the situation but
i'm here with you
through no matter what
um
we've been through
everything especially me and you like
like you and me feed each other's uh
yeah yeah yeah i got a lot of history
there was there was a point there was a
point that was just kind of me and you
like yeah
babalou
shout out to shaq shout out
insane anyway um
log net hide all the stuff that you do
knowing the stuff that you go through
and you still are pushing through
um
to see that documentary and to to
look at it and look at the people that
are willing to
push forward for a company we became an
llc this year
it has
been
my proudest moment
as your brother
brother to both of you
and the addict
because a lot of people
thought
because of my
lack of upbringing or
where i was from
because if you look at my projects that
i grew up in it's
probably the third most dangerous
projects in
new york city and no shout out
and to survive that
and to just want to be a part of
something
completely different
than my surroundings
because i knew if i stayed in those
surroundings
i would not be sitting here having a
conversation with all these wonderful
people that i get a chance to meet every
week and i meet you guys
enthusiastically
with all of my heart
and is the reason why i'm on twitter all
day long and having so much fun
with all the individuals on twitter
because i could have been either six
feet under
or
in places that
no
human being should be
so again
you guys make it possible for me to be
me and be accepted and to have a great
time
with games
something pure something fun something
that we can share together with and
don't feel ashamed about because we
have become the greatest medium today
we outpace movies
we outpace uh any form of entertainment
video games yeah gaming
the ones the stuff that they they
laughed at us about the stuff that they
said it would never amount to anything
is a trillion dollar industry and i am
so happy that we are a part of this
petey
i love you to death
we went in a pandemic
two packs facts in the pandemics
remember pax had the cleanest place i've
never seen a place that could have my
whole life never seen so much clear outs
used yeah it was the best and we're
going to go again to pax this year no
doubt no doubt um love you to death
petey for all the hard work that you you
do
i love everything about you your
thoughtfulness you hit me up the other
day making sure your attention to detail
is second to none and i really
appreciate you trust me from the bottom
of my heart um all the log net all the
hard work that you guys put in
lyric
i was so happy to have you on today to
have these conversations with you to see
to learn more about you because i get a
chance to see you with solve and solve
taking up all your minutes
more
about the individual that writes so
eloquently
and it's that is a part of this
wonderful team i do appreciate you we
don't ever take off i'm one of the
hardest working dudes that never want to
take off and they have to force me to
take off but
this time this year i really need a
break we all need it i just want to get
attic because i know he's remote i had
to get here on your phone and see can
you yeah yeah yeah yeah say some words
to the people reflect on 2021 before we
get into 2022 and you know just our
journey this year
2022 i mean 2021 and even 2020 like
in a world
that was screaming everyone do bad we we
we picked up the football we ran with it
it's like you know we uh we probably had
our biggest flux of guests this year
like by far yes i mean we we
would we
name it cog like it was like the road to
e3 like it was crazy it was crazy like
every week it was a new high-profile
guest or something like that
yeah you know we
we almost
almost tripled in size
it's not until you showed me the numbers
and i don't really get too crazy with
the numbers but it's not too and you
were like yo this is where we were at
last year i was like yo that was more
than tripled
yeah i was like wow i couldn't believe
it so it is it's interesting sometimes
you do gotta look sometimes and see
what's going on but yeah i agree i agree
it's just you know and then
not to mention you know the podcast
wouldn't be where it is without the
community yeah you know we we we
we could go out there and we can do a
hundred percent and everything
but if ain't nobody watching you know it
it's it's does that does the tree make a
noise
world no one great place
it's nice you know
uh
we we just had a good year man we've had
a good year
i don't think this year in terms of
games was like amazing but even games
wise it was still a good year so it's
just like this year in the gaming
industry i always say that
we it's influencers
people uh you know
big stream content creators big
streamers
we're making this
hobby
that we were clowned on growing up into
a mainstream thing for
our children for our brothers
that's the fact that's the fact i want
to give you your flowers in reference to
um your persistence and um
you know not giving up with guests
because even me you know i'm careful to
stop bro i got ego you unread my my
message i i might not talk to you no
more you know what i'm saying so i used
to get mad with a lot of these dudes no
comments you know you know how petey
know right there's a lot of these dudes
that you know it took a while for them
to to get in tune with the lords
but once they got in tune it was just
like yo just let us have a voice you
know i'm saying because i think you're
gonna have a good time if you come on
the show right if you come on you're
gonna have a good time we're gonna
celebrate you and we don't play that
game like if you're the biggest person
great if you're up and coming and we see
potential great like there's not going
to be that thing and i got to shout out
because there was a lot of times i was
getting frustrated and to see it kind of
turn around you know what i mean and i
was like okay that that's pretty dope
and because of that a lot of these
different
series of moves that kind of led me to
personal opportunities for me and i'm
saying because again if
attic doesn't reach out
to get colin
right
colin comes on acg comes on maddie comes
on i get a chance to go on duke
that doesn't happen
because i'm the person that's like yo if
someone didn't respond to my first email
you know what i'm saying i'm you know
whatever and he's not that like he's
going to be only like he's like we're
going to make this and i'm like hi you
know what i'm saying i trust in that i'm
going to let you rock and a lot of stuff
happened you know as a result of it and
um i want to shout you out that because
you don't get enough credit for a lot of
stuff you do in the background and you
know even petey knows that there's
certain guests and stuff that we were
just like man like it would be cool we
would never think this was gonna happen
and then it happens finally you know
saying a lot of it is persistence and
not giving up so salute to you on that
for sure yeah what's funny is like a lot
of these big guests that i've got on
like um the xcom developer i code
approached yes
the the the the 343 developer we had on
i code approached the compulsion
it's just the only thing i i
i have i'm uncomfortable yeah well code
approaching is women because i'm like i
ain't trying to have no pop up
everyone that came on this year man you
know especially thank you you know what
what what we've done personally you know
cogs out there reaching for the stars
and he's he's grabbed one of them so
you know uh you know we we
oh the only way we go is high up man
that's all we can [ __ ]
makes your best so i just want to get
those bars off um i know fonz and um pd
uh you know and uh lady lyric i'll let
y'all get y'all bars off if i have
anything to say in reference to this
subject and then we can just move on so
anyone can say anything if they they
choose well
go ahead and say something i guess um
yeah i just want to say that and i i
might sound like a broken record because
i tell you cog all the time
you guys what you do here for the
community is just flat out special
um
there is no other gaming podcast like
this
period there just isn't
um it's it's my favorite by far uh when
it comes to gaming podcasts you guys
rule
thank you uh i i really
your success you know all of your
success has been amazing because i
remember
coming here when there was 10 people in
the chat
and i i was sitting there in the chat
going why isn't more people watching
this what's going on here and then i dm
you i'm like why doesn't people why
don't people watch you absolutely and
like i couldn't believe
and then i started sending you texts
like maybe you should try this maybe you
should change days and you're like now
this is what works for us this day
you were right about that but
at the at the same time i'm just like i
want more eyes and ears on this podcast
yes and
and then you would reach out and say you
know they want me to get rid of the
intros somebody said something should i
get rid of them and i'm like
hell no don't get rid of the intro and i
wanna i wanna point out it's like we
brought up the community
people like colin you know these big big
guests we've had
it helps
to go to them now
with we have this type of reach we have
this type of demographic and that that's
because of the chat like like back in
the day these people i've hit up you
know it's not necessarily the people
we've spoken about like other content
creators and stuff that they they were
they were leaving us all red but the
bigger we got the more they're like okay
maybe i can get a little clap from yeah
of course they do that
of course but it you know what you guys
had was always there
it and then that's the thing like i was
just talking to somebody about you
guys's uh podcast just the other night
and i told them in a party chat
they have been this way since the
beginning
like you guys
just just the fact that you're all
friends you're just cutting up about you
know games and stuff
and it's just a beautiful thing like you
don't get that on on a lot of podcasts
out there shout out to delilah hd she
said that grown woman gave me clothes
she's like but i'm buying you know what
we're doing the same type of thing too
women
why don't you guys respond to messages
wow
i do want to point out you know
a couple people like that that have
always been down since the day we met
them randolph thor
diller gaming cody sword like
like
mr boom double barrel
hold up hold up you better be saying me
too
i never uh a chance to give fawns his
roses oh man
hijacked well he i thought he was on the
phone because he couldn't stay low
that's why yeah no
i'm on the phone i'm about to leave but
yeah i just want like you know bg fawns
like yeah you know a lot of these big
content creators they had no business
coming on our platform hip-hop gamer we
can't even forget him like he's my guy
like i don't think people realize when
these big content creators that actually
have a good following and comes on our
show it benefits us greatly because it
exposes us to a new community
and they're willing to come on here
because they see the chat so clean so
thanks for the chat because you know
that really helps when you see that chat
and it's not crazy salute salute yeah
but
i'm sorry
i'm sorry yeah it's just you know i just
i wanted to say i didn't get a chance to
you know talk glowingly about fonz
because fonz has always been there
like fonz
i don't know one day i think i was going
off on something whatever a tangent or
something
franz hit me the dm you
but that was okay that that was real i
wanted to know if you were all right are
you having a mental breakdown
[Laughter]
but
it's it's those is those questions uh
from somebody that kids in that space
you know um
you you got to understand i really
really respected that
and that meant a lot to me
because you reached out
yo what's up do you need to talk about
something i'm here
and you know you mean a lot to me you
know all of you do i mean that's that's
why i did it but you know what i love
when i told you you had the voice oh
yeah we had to tell them that voice yeah
and i showed my wife your show
right um from from from from the intro
to the show
is that games talk live is that yeah
she said she loves the vibe
and there's nothing else like and i said
i told him long time ago put your face
out there
and
when you did it yeah and i was on i was
happy as a pig and slop
trust me
because i know exactly how you what i'm
supposed to see i saw it and your show
oozes fine it's original yeah
when you say something like whack yeah
somebody could say whack but
why is it
different yes you understand so
i salute you for being you sir i do
appreciate you
like like seriously uh you guys you know
i remember when i started that and i
said hey you want to come on the show
you guys immediately said yes of course
you know honestly that that means a lot
because i i you know i do look up to you
guys um
because of what you do here on ilp and
that's what we're celebrating here is is
the fact that
i i really appreciate what all of you do
you all bring something different to the
table you addict and solve incognito of
course with his hosting ability best in
the business as far as i'm concerned
thank you brother uh you know and uh
yeah and and you deserve a lot more
success cog you really do just like king
said earlier you you honestly deserve
more and uh i i see that coming for you
in the future i really do i think this
gaming space for you is going to blow up
even bigger
ilp is just going to be taken up and
elevated along with you and it's just a
beautiful thing
i wish you guys continued success for
sure i appreciate your brother petey he
was going to say something
uh yeah well i mean i've been every
single year that i've been working with
the crew
uh in the background i mean it's been
almost three years now three
and
i will say that
the group of people
are
fantastic
you know from
i've known cog for for years
and when i met him and i think it was
him
addict and
king
at pax that the first time
i was like
who the heck are these guys
and then i listened then i started
listening to the podcast and i was
instantly hooked and i was like
i need to i need to get with these guys
i need to help them i need to do
whatever we could do to
help
you know to take care of some of the
pressure from from these guys
and um
every single every single week and like
you know almost every single almost
every day i should say
there's some way or shape or form
something's coming across the table
going
hey i think we should do this hey we
think we should do that and i'm like and
i kind of
that we kind of have a conversation and
i will say that
between everything that that
the team has done
for the past two years especially with
everything going down
um from the day from the day we left pax
was pretty much the last the last day of
freedom yeah and then it was like
and then it was like covered lockdown
boom two years
um
so
but this show has really shown me how
friendship
really can prevail and having a
community
behind you all
is so
so empowering to help each other and
grow together
that it really is one of the pinnacles
of
uh you know my week and probably
everyone else's week
so i appreciate you guys for taking
the time to make it what i remember the
first thing i said to you b i said your
podcast is way too damn long yep yeah i
was like i was like this thing is long
but for you guys to be able to do this
every week and everyone to be able to
come in here and love it and you know
even i appreciate it um i would like to
say you know generally
to to the four of you and to all the
guests
all the lognet people
you know and all the the longtime
supporters
um you know like you said before
like this weekend this week this year
has been
a a year cog for for you and for
for everybody else and even for maine
and
it's been
it's been nice to have that solid ground
to think of oh yeah and i love love
lately so i appreciate you guys i
appreciate it appreciate lyric let you
close out anything you wanted to say
ilp log lint 2021
well yeah um this january will make a
year since i have joined long night and
i remember so clearly seeing an article
on twitter and going to the site and
looking at like i want to do that i want
to write for this site
and i put in my information and the very
next day josh sent me the email josh
ready that
he was like we want you to join a team
and i was like okay and usually when i
sign up to write for a site it's
probably one or two articles but i was
excited when he sent me the discord link
because i was like well this is an
actual team
of people that support each other and
care about each other and
well you know if it wasn't for joe like
i was a person that was never going to
do on camera work and josh asked us
about lord's minute and i was like i'll
do it
i remember i remember i remember i was
like yeah she did
and i want to shout out
everybody for being supportive
especially because
you know i lost my aunt this year and
people
cog hit me up in my twitter dms and
checked on me and you guys donated to
her you know home sending
yes you know
that meant a lot it meant a lot that not
only that i don't know if you're
comfortable with me talking about it but
like
help put money in my pocket like
me and macho of course so whenever you
express disappointment that you can't
pay us i don't look at it that way i
look at it like this is an artist
collective and we're all striving to
build this up and make this better so
i'm happy to be here and
you know if one day you do put that
contract in front of me i'm not even
gonna think about it i'm just gonna sign
it
love says you know at the end of the day
i'm glad you said it too because you
know one thing with lognet is what we're
actually proud of if you had this
conversation pd um and even the entire
editorial which is like
we are never going to try to stop anyone
from an opportunity and if this is a
jumping point off to something great for
you then that but we want the blessing
you know because when we're getting
looked at by the bigger entities and
saying hey
we like your team we like you know
whatever i'm always going to give a
recommendation i'm not going hold on out
of this [ __ ] with us
okay you know what i'm saying like like
it ain't live cause at the end of the
day it's like we're all striving for
greater things and you succeeding
is a blessing to us and it legitimizes
us so
yeah like that that's that's nothing you
know that that is what we're about you
know josh and i had that conversation
mark moon and i have had that
conversation as well as um
nicholas downey like
the opportunities we go we're going to
try to put you in position to win and
that's what it's about so salute to you
you were putting in the work and uh
sky's the limit girl
also shout out to my
sort of our
three-person crew on twitter of me flame
hooray
they'll be encouraging plate
that's all good that's all i got um
so if what we do is because i know we
got everybody hostage
yeah yeah i mean we don't we
we don't have that many but let me
actually i forgot to give my my flowers
over here to petey and and fonza and
april so real quick like
um first off petey petey from the moment
i've known you you are
you're kind
you and hyde are kind of the rock behind
uh behind iop and behind lognet and my
brother of course the kaibatsu as well
who puts up the
the sound and stuff after
um
but you guys like
what you guys do to sort of just make
things
flow and run smoothly like you said is
is absolutely so essential because again
all of us are kind of like
dragging our feet sometimes we just
don't have the time to be able to do it
and the fact that you could do that for
us and kind of just
elevates everything that we do so i
appreciate it uh immensely and i i am
sorry for making you edit so much
it's fine
and then my brother fonz fonz
when i talked earlier about how i have
ten i can count all my friends on ten
fingers but the but the community sort
of showed me that there are people here
that kind of
i would let in into that circle fond is
one of those people
fonz is absolutely
one of the most genuine yes people i've
met in this community everything he says
and does is heartfelt
and he shares that same passion for
gaming and for life that we do so it was
very easy to connect with fawns and i i
loved you know i love the fact that
you kind of this year decided hey i'm
gonna go do my own thing as well i'm
gonna go do this and i'm gonna do it my
way uh it was such a great honor for me
to be on your show and just just to rap
back and forth with you because i knew
that's what it was going to be it's like
that buzzer though exactly
i would i was terrified of the questions
i'm like i'm going to fail oh my god
um but it was it was great to be there
because brother i'd love to have you on
more often man oh man i would love to be
on more often
but it is that thing of like the same
energy i feel with these guys here i
feel with you it is it is that thing
like there's a kinship you feel so i
really i appreciate you for being there
um
immensely and april
i gotta tell you
when they
when when we started doing laura's
minute and and josh says to me i'm gonna
put you in april
i think you two would be a perfect fit
and i didn't know what that meant i
didn't know what that meant because i
hadn't engaged with any of your stuff
before so when i go on and i see
i see a lot of myself in april
where it's like again back in the day i
i was you had to extract words from me
back in the day and i noticed initially
she's very quiet whatever but she's
super intelligent it's just a matter of
kind of engaging her to speak so i'm
like okay the same stuff that i went
through
i'm gonna put her through all right i'm
gonna put her
sort of to just to sort of
get her off the shelf
and once you do
like me can't get it to shut up
i love your takes on on
on sort of the the
the sort of
kind of the the political side and and
the sort of societal side of our
industry and and the things that need to
be improved upon and that i love the way
you talk about that stuff how passionate
you are about it and
um i just love the way you think about
gaming because again somebody who's
considerably younger than we are the
passion is there the same passion is
there we share the same things for us to
be able to be kind of that distant in
terms of age and still sort of be able
to connect in the way we do i love it i
i i'm so happy for the things you've
accomplished so far and for what's
coming ahead because i know even bigger
things are coming for you so thank you
for sharing a microphone with me every
week
mostly every week
most of your 20 minutes
let's wrap up um
solvers get the supers everybody that
has to leave please because we got to
get take care of business
i i've got to run because i've got to go
do my thing you've got a show i've got a
show in a couple hours and i want to see
i want to get things done yes you know
brother fox thank you brother perfect
thank you for
i'm glad we was able wat link hey i i'm
so glad you know i hit you up from time
to time i'm like dude i'd love to be on
cameo anything like you know oh yeah i i
love being around this energy all the
time seriously you guys put out a
positive influence within this gaming
community
like none other
honestly love brother enjoy your sunday
i'll catch you petey i know you're about
to head out most likely
i'm i'm good
okay okay cool the wife is not here
[Music]
she has taken the baby and left the room
so we are good no doubt about that lady
lyric if you gotta go it's totally
understanding because we gotta read
these super chats and it's all good
there aren't that many though
okay okay cool so let's get it okay hold
on let me a few more popped in so let me
just roll back
for a moment
let me see
[Music]
shout out to y'all with the moment
yeah yeah some fun moments in there
yeah we had some moments that's oh yeah
oh yeah
so let's do the best of moments clips
oh that'd be funny okay ready to go
let's go we have spartan go 17 two pound
super chat microsoft should get day one
and game pass not timed exclusives yeah
i think that's kind of what king was
talking about like
clutch man ten dollars if you chat
there's a clear difference in the
leadership personalities interviewed
though people who acknowledge mistakes
as i made them and one who said there
were mistakes we made just saying that's
something i alluded to
yeah it is you know it's interesting how
people talk yeah um then we have rob the
dawn 202 five dollar super chat
it's funny with the power with the power
on documentary nobody's mentioning how
gta was almost an xbox exclusive yeah
imagine how things might be different
almost don't count
yeah it's just crazy it's just crazy how
again little things could change back
then they would have probably came out
messed up we good
hilarious
then we got splendiferous
remember for three months shout out to
you sir normally i would be coming at
lord saw pause
but sure but addict out here sounded
like sony dropped him a bag or a couple
tell us what you know playboy
yo this is so funny we can't even
slightly defend playstation
we got a bag we got a bag
oh it is that's how it is out here i
wish it were that easy damn
and we got splendiferous once again two
dollar super chat your cog is killing me
with that continue so fluent
let's go
there we go stance five dollar super
chat i think it's only lost more people
during their first hacking incident than
xbox red ring issue did sony ever
apologize for that i mean
did they come i don't remember
um
kind of no backhanded
nah you know what was funny they could
tell you
this video all right so yeah somebody
charged 500 on your account
it was uh how many games all right cool
what's your gamer tag yeah yeah i didn't
do it
let me have my money back and you go to
your gamer tag is blocked
i remember that i didn't thankfully
didn't get hacked nobody stole any money
from me but what i remember vividly from
that time is that this whole incident
folded socom
like it's so complicated
[Music]
because of this
uh we got d.d lee member for 18 months
thank you sir
unofficially the best xbox podcast out
right now my favorite
my favorite moments was jamaican jim
ryan yeah that was crazy shout out to dd
lee um he got he wanted to shout him out
because he he cop two um pieces of merch
but he forgot about that he let me know
he got to throw him in the bushes long
sleeve tee and he got the all daddy long
sleeve teeth hey guys um
jamaican jim is going to have to go back
to jamaica
because of
i want you to think about it this way
um
imagine somebody makes a caricature of
you yeah
and imagine that character
is hilarious
all right
now i don't know how you might take the
joke um but
i wouldn't be too enthused about it at
some point in time so um i have to
respectfully send
uh him to jamaica maybe
maybe delroy might show up
that has absolutely nothing to do with
him
but uh you know maybe you might get
another uh relative
to show up
out of control
uh there we have army veteran five
dollars if we check merry christmas and
happy new my favorite time is when king
goes off
and jamaican and jamaican chips
got his roses
then we got nam omar member for four
months shout out to you sir thank you
another amazing year for the iop
jamaican gym was definitely the biggest
hit of the year
[ __ ] drinking my type
there we go cheney ten dollars to be
chat happy holidays to the realm in the
lords and worldwide gym right
i'm looking forward to a prosperous new
year for the realm your interviews are
go see you in 2020 thank you sir thank
you jim is eating kiwi fruit
come on
then we have ultra msv
five dollar super chat my favorite
moment is discovering you guys i've been
entertained since and a huge thanks to
cog for his health is wealth model thank
you brother you're doing it yeah i gotta
push it help this buff all day we gotta
be around for these games
right
right now no it's not the time
member for three months
merry christmas and happy new year lords
enjoy the holidays and be back next year
with longer intros
yes worldwide gym see you next year
he got no wi-fi
he got
[Music]
well great year so far the wife and i
are expecting a daughter any day now oh
stage that's what hold me right there
hope it's not at christmas or new year's
day see you all next year enjoy like
wise to you and blessings man i heard
davina is a great name
ridiculous bro i i tried to get addict
to read this last week i'm gonna have to
read it
mandingo mcficken
what's his name mandico what man dingo
mcthicken
[Music]
wow
i
you guys are appreciated keep up the
excellent work you guys are the perfect
store thank you sir
the most epic name ever
this is my first year kicking it with
the iop and i can't wait to see what's
next in 2022 merry christmas and happy
new year everybody same to you sir much
appreciated no doubt no doubt there we
have sober king two to two pound and
fifty pence super chat happy holidays
lords respect you all and addict
wow
he hates that he hates that
he's some sorrow
slow-mo started that that was slow yeah
that was slow
then we got uh
doomy
happy holidays to the crew another great
year watching you all favorite moment
happens every week and icing on the cake
king with all the knees he had to take
along with jamaican jam
shout out to jay barry for ending off my
my
with the knees
single-handedly made 2020 and 2021
bearable thank you
yeah always start the year off of blaze
4k knees
then we got flame once again five dollar
super chat you rang april love y'all too
though thanks for giving me a new
purpose on life here unlocked and don't
ever change this podcast
for sure hold on let me roll back
because we got a couple of more
okay we got jd
50 super chat thank you so much bro
happy holidays and merry christmas lords
keep being you absolutely
hold us down
but
then we got lord metroid two dollar
super chat iop moment king thinking
skyward sword is good
what's your metro are you doing in the
bushes
always
[Laughter]
the last
2021 update retired jim ryan now on ps5
game pass
okay
then we got doomy once again remember
for 13 months 13 months is easy to be a
member with all the savings from having
game packs
this is true that's like a commercial
because because he saves money on game
pass he's able to see he's able to see
what appreciates that
you can play me and you can play uh
mortal kombat 11 that just came out
just came out the awesome
uh
then we got black ronin remember for
eight months thank you sir shout out to
the roman lords your show is awesome and
i can't wait to see what you all bring
in 2022.
one year
then we got don otaku five dollar super
chat my iop moment is when the lords had
a taste of the crystal d
let that crystal d rain on the realm
into the noodles
by having the taste of the christian
deep fair
you going laughs
he going left salute
everybody enjoy man this is a fantastic
yeah do the outros real quick lady lyric
a i love where can the five people find
you what you have going on
well you can find me on instagram it's
lyric i love 95 you can find me on
twitter at lyric i love if you can
if you happen to see me at walmart
you sure you want them to do
buy me a subway sandwich first though
there you go
salute no doubt get down get around a
lot of fun lord petey slando tv
working upon people find what you got
going on sir
uh
first of all let's say
thanks guys for letting me uh slide in
at least once a year full finale over
here appreciate it
i don't know who let you slide up
[Laughter]
[Music]
thanks my friends um
uh yeah uh do we got a lot cool things
coming up for uh for the podcast for you
guys coming up next year
uh
i got a bunch of videos actually in the
uh
in the pipe for us to be edited and
brought out so you got a lot of pause
worth your stuff
dude i'm a
busy man i got a lot of videos in the
pike come on man
savage and on that note uh
on everything uh and i'm on twitch uh
five days a week from three to eleven
every single day
so if you need me i am there shout out
to pd see you soon we got stuff cooking
you already know can i wait no doubt
lord sav we're gonna find people find
you what you gotta do now big shout out
to april and to pete and defense for
coming through um you can find me
chilling i am next week i will be back
in the motherland where you going
chilling out be up eat up you know for
the holidays you know how they go ah
come
so uh big shout out to everybody again
enjoy your holidays happy and safe new
year to everyone love y'all
see you on the other side you already
know and of course the king
where can i find who finds what you got
going on sir you'll find me on twitter
being a troll
provocateur
he told me he told jason
now you know why because i got to
respect the fact that he is a journalist
like you went to school and you've done
this thing here
i can't sit up here and act like i'm i'm
going to do investigative journalism
i'm here to stir the pot baby yeah
you know you know the great thing is
that jason understands that because he
himself is a bit of he knows he's got a
little provocation he knows what he does
i love all the stuff that he's about i
love all the stuff
but you can find me on twitter being a
troll um
you can find me
um
watching fights and uh actually putting
my feet up for
the next two weeks actually
getting a little bit of rest on sunday
cause
if y'all don't know yeah i'm up 24 hours
when i do this show
so after this
um
but uh god i do appreciate everything
see y'all next year
2022. it'll be fantastic uh you guys
have a happy solstice uh 21st celebrate
give gifts give kisses love and hug um
but most of all reflect and be thankful
because a lot of people didn't wake up
today yeah
so i don't care what circumstances you
got you got breath and you can change
those circumstances so always be
thankful for just waking up factual be
appreciative don't doubt stop getting
super chat the couple will flow and then
we roll up but we got dragon heart yobe
five dollars will be chat king is the p
king is the ps5 considered the roach
motel as well since it has that
generator inside
it's nice and warm for them
for the fire next to the barbie
wow
[Laughter]
you know what it is that's that's that's
that's that's young boy terminology
funny i find really hilarious
know what it is
continue on your playstation 5.
out of control there we go
all the lords coming up to possible
packs east next year um factual
we will be there boston in the building
pull up sir
yeah we got suicide kings 5 super chat
with no disrespect to anyone else thank
you iop for the finest and most
entertaining podcast in the gaming
business continued success thank you sir
it's all because of people like you
then we have
splendiferous five dollar super chat
lord saab hasn't been wilding out lately
so this holiday i think you've earned
your gravy for your meat
he got more for you
so don't eat too fast and choke playboy
[Music]
i'm gonna tell you
i'm gonna tell you i'm gonna tell you
this splendiferous um you know i don't
know you want to be in this chat next
year when horizon when a horizon starts
walling out when kratos makes his way i
don't know
i don't know you got the gravy for your
meat
[Laughter]
what was your other bad name oh
man
yo happy new year all that good stuff
enjoy your holiday the laws will return
on january
9th at 1pm eastern we will be back
that's right 1pm eastern generating that
enjoy
love y'all that's all that's
right he said watch out for the more
cj's
that's the that's the that's the blood
pudding that looks like oh
no we're not doing that we're not doing
it
never mind
merry christmas song exactly peace of
love happy new year love y'all next year
peace
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
so
you